GENERAL WILL BEGIN IN SIXTY
SECONDS. THERE WAS NO VERB IN
THAT SENTENCE BUT I INCLUDED ONE.
SENATE BUDGET INVESCO REVIEW
BECAUSE SUBCOMMITTEE FOR WILL
COME TO ORDER- THIS IS A LEAD
SCRIPT SOMEWHERE BUT I'M JUST
GONNA SAY WERE OPERATING AS A
SUB COMMITTEE BECAUSE I'M THE
ONLY ONE HERE MEMBERS ARE MAKING
THEIR WAY BUT WE WILL HAVE A
SERIES OF DISCUSSIONS ON A
NUMBER OF ITEMS FIRST BEFORE WE
GOING TO VOTE ONLY HAVING SAID
THAT IF YOU ARE ON THIS
COMMITTEE I ENCOURAGE YOU
MEMBERS TO MAKE YOUR WAY. TO
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED GOOD MORNING
AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN RISKS THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE PUBLIC
AND HAS PROVIDED ACCESS TO BOTH
IN PERSON AND TELECONFERENCE BUT
DISSIPATION FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS THE
PARTICIPANTS FROM TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED
ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT RIGHT NOW IS
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
FOUR ONE ONE ONE FOUR ZERO AND
THE PHONE SERVICE IS WORKING. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE- STREET BUILDING. I
ASK ALL MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE BE PRESENT IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM AND
BEGINNER HEARING WHAT WE ARE
BEGINNING IT AS A SIDE BECAUSE
NO ONE IS HERE. I THINK THEY
SHOULD BE CALLED THE E. STREET
BUILDING INSTEAD OF THE- STREET
BUILDING BUT THAT'S ANOTHER KIND
OF DISCUSSION. YOU KNOW- BRUCE
SPRINGSTEEN THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE ALSO PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES ARE YOUR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK AND I ASK
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZE THAT TO USE THE RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM
EACH TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO AND MUTE PLEASE SELECT ON MU
BEFORE HE BEGINS SPEAKING OUR I.
T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK
ON YOU WHEN YOU ARE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN. STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING
ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. AGAIN PUBLIC COMMENT WILL
BE HEARD AFTER ALL DISCUSSION
ITEMS HAVE BEEN PRESENTED. LET'S
DO THIS FOR FUN MISTER HACKER.
THREE ESTABLISH A CORN ALL WE
CANNOT I AM THE ONLY ONE HERE
OKAY HEY WE WILL JUST OPERATE AS
A SUB COMMITTEE. WE HAVE TWO
PARTS OF THE AGENDA TODAY WE
WILL BE DISCUSSING ALL ISSUES
I'M JUST GONNA MAKE MYSELF LAUGH
TODAY WE WILL BE DISCUSSING ALL
ISSUES LISTED IN THE DISCUSSION
SECTIONS A PART EIGHT AND PART
B. AGENDA AFTER WE HEAR ALL
DISCUSSION ITEMS IN PART A AND
PART B. WE WILL THEN GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR BOTH PART. A
AND B. AFTER PUBLIC COMMENT WE
WILL VOTE ON THE ISSUES IN EACH
PART OF THE AGENDA AS- SO WE
WILL BEGIN. WITH PART EIGHT
ISSUE THIRTY SEVEN ON THE
GAMBLING CONTROL COMMISSION A
LICENSING FEE METHODOLOGY
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. GAMING
CONTROL COMMISSION ARE YOU HERE.
YOU ARE HERE MISS DAISY LUNA
BAXTER AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENTS. YES THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CHAIR. MY NAME IS STACY
LANE A LITTLE BACKSTORY NINE THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION. TODAY I AM JOINED BY
OTHER ON I'LL CALL OF THE SHARA
OR GET THE DIRECTOR FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE AND REGULATORY
AFFAIRS DIVISION. TO PROVIDE
SOME BACKGROUND SUPPORTING THIS
REQUEST IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
MCCARTY M. INDUSTRY REQUESTED AN
AUDIT THROUGH THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE. AND
AUDIT WAS CONDUCTED AND MAY
TWENTY NINETEEN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR ISSUED. ITS AUDIT
REPORT AND FORMALLY RECOMMENDED
THAT THE COMMISSION CONDUCT
ACOSTA V. ANALYSIS AND ADJUST
OUR FEES TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
IN ALIGNMENT WITH REGULATORY
COSTS. IMMEDIATELY UPON THE
RELEASE OF THE AUDITOR'S REPORT.
THE COMMISSION CONTRACTED WITH
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED EXPERTS IN
COSTA SERVICE ANALYSIS AND
REVENUE RECOVERY AND GT
CONSULTING. TO CONSTRUCT AN
EXTENSIVE CUSTODY ANALYSIS
IMPERFECT PROPOSED A FEET
RESTRUCTURING. THIS
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT VIA BT THE
COMMISSION AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE'S BUREAU OF GAMBLING
CONTROL. ONCE THE ANALYSIS IN
RESTRUCTURING PROPOSAL WERE
FINALIZED THEY WERE SUBMITTED TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
THE STATE AUDITOR AND
SUBSEQUENTLY APPROVED IN. LATE
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE
AUDITORS WHO AND THE ANALYSIS
CONDUCT CONFER THAT THE CARD
ROOM. FEE METHOD. AS CURRENT SET
IN STATUTE DOES NOT ADEQUATELY
THE TRUE REGULATORY COSTS
ASSOCIATED. THE COMMISSION HAS
FULL REGULATORY AUTHORITY TO
MODIFY ALL BUT ONE OF ITS FEES
THE CARD OR MANUAL THREE. THE
COMMISSION HAS ALREADY REPORT
THOSE BEES MARC FOR REDUCTION.
URGENT REGULATORY. AND IS IN THE
FINAL STAGE THROUGH ITS
REGULATORY AUTHORITY TO ADJUST
ALL OTHER FEES. WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE CARD ANNUAL FEE
. THE PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE SEEKS TO ALLOW THE
COMMISSION TO MODIFY THE CARTER
MANUAL FEED THROUGH THE FORMAL
REGULATORY PROCESS WHICH WOULD
BE CONSISTENT WITH HOW WE HANDLE
ALL OTHER FEES. IF THE PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS
APPROVED THE COMMISSION WILL AND
MUST STILL PROMULGATE THE CARD
ROOM IN NORTH FEET VIA
REGULATIONS UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT.
AS SUCH THE REGULATIONS WILL
PROVIDE MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STAKEHOLDER PARTICIPATION ANDULTIMATELY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND OFFICE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW. REVIEW AND
APPROVAL. WITHOUT THE APPROVAL
OF THE TRAILER BILL THE
COMMISSION WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
COMPLETE THE STATE AUDITOR'S
FROM WORK. OR CHARGE THE CARD
ROOMS IN A PRE ANNUAL FEE THAT
IS ALIGNMENT WITH THE ACTUAL
REGULATORY COSTS. WE DO
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
CONSIDERATION HOPEFULLY SUPPORT
OF THIS ITEM AND WE ARE HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PROVIDE ANY COMMENT. GOOD
MORNING KEVIN CLARK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. VERY GOOD
L. A- WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROVIDE
ANY COMMENT. NEARLY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE NO
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW
OPEN THE DISCUSSION QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR CAFIERO DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. NO PORTION. OKAY
SERA'S DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
ARE NOT HERE YET SENATOR NIELSEN
YOU'RE NOT HERE YET ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU NOW LET'S MOVE TO
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT
STUDENT BORROWER LOAN ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION IN INNOVATION WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PRESENTS. I SHOULD
MENTION I'M SORRY ITEM THIRTY-
WITH THIS IS A HOLD- TO HOLD
OPEN ITEM FOR- ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTY SEVEN. YOU WILL MOVE ON
YAK ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT
I'M SORRY DAPI. GREAT JOB
MANAGER I'M CRUCIAL TIME THE
CHIEF DEPUTY COMMISSIONER AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION INNOVATION THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY TEN BUDGET
INCLUDES TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
COMMUNICATIONS EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH CAMPAIGN. OUT WITH ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND DOLLARS TO SIX
STUDENT LOAN BORROWERS WHO FACED
CRITICAL DECISIONS IN THE LATTER
HALF OF CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO YOU. THE BY
DEMONSTRATION HAS ANNOUNCED
PLANS TO RESTART STUDENT LOAN
PAYMENTS IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THE REPAYMENT
RESTART DATE IS MOVED A COUPLE
TIMES. IN THE PAST YEAR BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT FUNDS BE APPROVED
THIS SPRING SO WE'RE READY TO GO
WHENEVER THE FIGHTING
MINISTRATION TURNS STUDENT LOAN
REPAYMENT BACK ON. SECOND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR
PUBLIC AGENCIES AND NONPROFITS
MAY BE ELIGIBLE FOR EXPANDED
ACCESS TO WHAT'S CALLED PUBLIC
SERVICE LOAN FORGIVENESS BUT I
HAVE TO TAKE SPECIFIC ACTION BY
OCTOBER THIRTY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. IF WE CAN HELP EASE
CALIFORNIANS GET THEIR STUDENT
LOANS FORGIVEN THAT'S MONEY THEY
CAN SPEND ON OTHER THINGS EVERY
YEAR INTO THE FUTURE. ARE HAVE
INCLUDED FLEXIBILITY FOR THE FBI
TO ADJUST THE TIMING OF OUR
EFFORTS IF THE BY
ADMINISTRATION- CONTINUES TO
MOVE THE STATE. AND WITH FACULTY
OVER MY COLLEAGUES SUZANNE
MARTINDALE WHO'S AN EXPERT IN
THE STUDENT LOAN FIELD. THANK
YOU CHRIS AND GOOD MORNING SHARE
AND MEMBERS SO AT A TIME OF
GREAT ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY AND
ALL THESE FLUCTUATIONS IN
FEDERAL POLICY IT IS CRUCIAL FOR
STUDENT LOAN BORROWERS IN
REPAYMENT IN PAUSE TO UNDERSTAND
THEIR OPTIONS- LEARN HOW TO SPOT
SCAMS AND REPORT TROUBLING
BEHAVIOR TO OUR DEPARTMENT WHICH
LICENSES AND REGULATES THE
STUDENT LOAN INDUSTRY UNDER
MULTIPLE CALIFORNIA LAWS. AND
WE'RE HOME TO ALMOST FOUR
MILLION PEOPLE WITH OUTSTANDING
FEDERAL LOANS THAT HAVE BEEN ON
POLICIES THE ONSET OF THE
PANDEMIC IN MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
EACH OTHER MANY REPEATED SHORT
TERM EXTENSIONS OF THE PAYMENT
BECAUSE BY THE WHITE HOUSE BUT
THERE'S NO LONGER TERM PLAN YET
IN SIGHT. AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL
AND BECAUSE OF THAT BARBERS ARE
UNDERSTANDABLY ANXIOUS ABOUT
WHEN THEY HAVE TO START
REPAIRING AND THEY'RE WARY OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S MIXED
MESSAGES QUITE FRANKLY WE ARE
WORKING IN CLOSE COORDINATION
WITH THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION RUSSIA TALKING TO THEM
LATER TODAY- AND THEY'RE
ACTIVELY URGING STATE REGULATORS
LIKE OUR DEPARTMENT. SHOULD
PRIORITISE BOROUGH OUT THIS
SYSTEMS AS MUCH POSSIBLE
PARTICULARLY BETWEEN NOW AND
OCTOBER THIRTY FIRST WHEN NOT
PUBLIC SERVICE LOAN FORGIVENESS
WAIVER EXPIRES THAT DAY IT'S NOT
GOING. SO THE WAY TO HOLD THESE
LOANS IT'S VERY. I KNOW IT FOR
MY- OWN EXPERIENCES SOMEONE IS
HAD STUDENT LOANS WHO WENT
THROUGH THE PUBLIC SERVICE LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAM AND FINALLY.
GOT MY OWN LOANS CANCELED. EVEN
AS A LAWYER AND AN EXPERT IN
THIS SPACE I'VE BEEN DOING WORK
ON STUDENT LOAN POLICY FOR ABOUT
A DOZEN YEARS NOW. I STRUGGLE TO
RESOLVE MY OWN PROBLEMS WITH MY
LOAN SERVICER OVER THE YEARS AND
FOUND THE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES GOVERNING MY LOANS TO
BE CONFUSING. SO IT IS TO
OVERSTATE THE NEED PEOPLE HAVE
FOR CLEAR ACCURATE INFORMATION.
UPDATES AND REMINDERS ABOUT KEY
DEADLINES OPPORTUNITIES TO
ATTEND EVENTS AND ASK QUESTIONS
OF EXPERTS AND BETTER AWARENESS
OF HOW TO FILE COMPLAINTS WE
CAN'T RESOLVE A PROBLEM ON YOUR
OWN. IN FACT WE HAVE A COLLEAGUE
AN EMPLOYEE OR DEPARTMENT-
HIDDEN IN PAST TRYING TO GET HER
SERVICER. TO UPDATE HER PAYMENT
COUNT FOR THE PURPOSES OF PUBLIC
SERVICE LOAN FORGIVENESS YOU
FELT THEY WERE UNDER COUNTING
HER PAYMENTS. SHE FILED A FORMAL
COMPLAINT WITH OUR DEPARTMENT OR
PROGRAM TEAM GOT INVOLVED IN THE
SERVICE OR CORRECTED THE
PROBLEM. AND OUR EMPLOYEE
RECEIVED FIFTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN DEBT CANCELLATION- SO
THE ABILITY FOR A STATE
REGULATOR TO INTERVENE. IMPACT
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT EVERY.
BARRING CAN SUCCESSFULLY. THEIR
LOANS AND UP. SERVICE THE PUBLIC
SERVANTS INCLUDING OUR OWN STATE
EMPLOYEES WITH FEDERAL LOANS CAN
ACCESS THE BENEFITS OF PSLF.
THIS PROPOSAL WITH A NAIL ENABLE
US TO SCALE UP RESULTS LIKE
THIS. EXPANDING OUR OUTREACH
CAPACITY WORKING WITH COMMUNITY
PARTNERS. AND ENSURING THAT WERE
SUPPORTING COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS CAN ALSO PROVIDE
INDIVIDUALIZED COUNSELING OR
LEGAL ADVICE TO BORROWERS
DIRECTLY THANK YOU. THANK YOU S.
FINANCE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PROVIDE ANY COMMENT. FINANCE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROVIDE ANY
KIND OF EVERYONE FROM THE
FINANCE ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OF
THE SENATE. GREAT THANK YOU L.
A. O. WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROVIDE
ANY COMMENT. THE MANAGER WE
THINKING WITH LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. THE PROPOSAL
IN JANUARY AND AT BEGINNING ON
PAGE FORTY EIGHT. SEVERAL
CONSENSUS GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
APPROACH TO ASSISTING STUDENT
LOAN BORROWERS. OUR FIRST
CONCERN IS THAT THERE ARE MANY
EXISTING SOURCES OF INFORMATION
ON STUDENT LOANS AND REPAYMENT
INCLUDING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS WELL AS FROM
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES. THE
PROPOSAL DOESN'T IDENTIFY WHAT
SPECIFIC GAPS IN INFORMATION
REMAIN AFTER ACCOUNTING FOR
THESE EXISTING RESOURCES AND HOW
THE PROPOSED ACTIVITIES WITH
INVESTORS CATS. MOREOVER SOME OF
THE PROPOSED ACT IS MADE
DUPLICATE EXISTING RESOURCES.
FOR EXAMPLE A PORTION OF THE
PROPOSED FUNDS WOULD GO TOWARD
DEVELOPING A BARI FACING WEBSITE
ALL THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WHICH ADMINISTERS THE
FEDERAL STUDENT LOAN PROGRAM
ALREADY NINETEEN SUCH WEBSITE.
WE ARE CONCERNED WITH THE USE OF
ONE TIME FUNDS IN THIS WAY. I AM
TIMELY INFORMATION ON STUDENT
LOANS IT IS IN MANY WAYS AN
ONGOING ACTIVITY WITH A NEW
COHORT OF BORROWERS ENTERING
REPAYMENT EVERY YEAR. WHILE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL COULD REACH
CAR BUYERS IN THE NEAR TERM
THERE AREN'T CLEAR PROVISIONS
FOR SUSTAINING ACTIVITIES AFTER
THE FUNDING EXPIRES. CONCERN
HERE IS THE BACK COULD BE TO
SHORT LIVED IMPACT WHILE
CREATING PRESSURE FOR THE STATE
TO FIND ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
THIS PURPOSE TIMELINE. FINALLY
WE DO THE CONCERN ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF THE CONTINUED FEDERAL
CHANGES ON THIS PROPOSAL. AS THE
DEPARTMENT HAS DESCRIBED AS
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PUT A PAUSE
ON STUDENT LOAN REPAYMENTS AT
THE START OF THE COOK AT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND HAS SINCE
EXPANDED THAT PAUSE SEVERAL
TIMES. AT THIS STAGE IT'S
UNCLEAR WHETHER REPAYMENTS WILL
RESUME ON SEPTEMBER FIRST IS
CURRENTLY SCHEDULED. FOR THAT
DATE WILL BE FURTHER PUSHED BACK
FOR THE PORTION OF LOANS WILL BE
FORGIVEN ALTOGETHER. AMERICANS
INTO THIS UNCERTAINTY COULD
IMPACT THE STATE'S ABILITY TO
IMPLEMENT AN ACCURATE AND TIMELY
INFORMATION CAMPAIGN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. GIVEN
THESE CONCERNS WE THINK
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
REJECTING THIS PROPOSAL.
NONETHELESS IF THERE IS INTEREST
IN PROVIDING FUNDING FOR STUDENT
LOAN BORROWERS ASSISTANCE IN THE
COMING YEAR WE'LL BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH STAFF TO EXPLORE
OPTIONS TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS.THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THAT I JUST SUCH A WONDERFUL
DEMEANOR SAYING SO MANY
IMPORTANT THINGS- OKAY THANK YOU
AND WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP
DISCUSSION BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE BUT I FIRST WOULD LIKE
IF THERE CAN BE A RESPONSE TO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT THE L.
A. O. ADDRESSED. OF COURSE
DURING HUNDRED TO RESPOND TO
THAT AGAIN AS I NOTED AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IS
URGING US TO TAKE ACTION IN THE
SPACE THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION'S MATERIALS ARE. GOING
TO REFLECT WHAT IS FEDERAL
POLICY I WILL NOT REFLECT ANY OF
THE STATE LAWS ALSO GOVERN THE
STUDENT LOAN INDUSTRY WE
DIRECTLY LICENSE. FEDERAL
STUDENT LOAN SERVICERS HERE AT
THE STATE LEVEL WE EXAMINE THEM
TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE AND WE TAKE
CONSUMER COMPLAINTS. AS I
MENTIONED WE RECENTLY RESOLVED A
COMPLAINT THAT WAS FILED BY ONE
OF OUR OWN EMPLOYEES I'M HERE AT
THE STATE LEVEL WE CAN PROVIDE A
LEVEL OF SERVICE THAT YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO GET OUT OF WASHINGTON
DC. WE HAVE ALREADY BEEN HOSTING
AND CO HOSTING WEBINARS WHERE
OVER SOON WE'RE WE'VE BEEN
TAKING LIVE CULINARY THAT'S THE
KIND OF- THAT'S THE KIND OF WORK
THAT WE WANT TO EXPAND ON IT. AS
A PART OF THIS PROPOSAL TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE KNOW THAT WE
ARE HERE AS A RESOURCE. THERE
DOES YOUR STATE FINANCIAL
REGULATOR TO PROVIDE. TO PROVIDE
SERVICES NOT JUST IN TERMS OF
MATERIALS ON OUR WEBSITE WHICH
INCLUDES BOTH FEDERAL STATE AND
NONPROFIT RESOURCES AGAIN YOU'RE
NOT GONNA SEE THAT ON DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION'S WEBSITE BUT WE
ALSO POST WHEN WE HAVE UPCOMING
EVENTS AND WEBINARS WHERE PEOPLE
CAN SHOW UP TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LISTEN AND LEARN
AND- ALSO ASK US QUESTIONS. WE
ALSO INCLUDE OUR OWN CONTACT
INFORMATION AT THE YOU'VE SEEN A
SPIKE IN BOTH COMPLAINTS AND
ALSO JUST EMAIL ENQUIRIES ASKING
FOR. INFORMATION ABOUT OPTIONS
BECAUSE OF FLUCTUATIONS IN
FEDERAL POLICY FARMERS ARE
DISTRUSTFUL OF FEDERAL RESOURCES
ON THEIR OWN THEY WANT TO
VALIDATE IT WANNA SECOND OPINION
IF YOU WILL. I'M AND SO WE ARE
OFTEN GETTING QUESTIONS FROM
PEOPLE WHO WENT TO THE
DEPARTMENT'S WEBSITE THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S
WEBSITE. THEY'RE STILL NOT SURE
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO TRUST IT
AND SO WE HAVE A WE ARE FINDING
THAT WE PLAYED A KEY ROLE HERE
IS THAT IS THE STATE FINANCIAL
REGULATORS IN BEING A RESOURCE.
TO STUDENT LOAN BORROWERS OF
VALIDATE OR GIVEN THE MISTRUST
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AT
THIS TIME AND AGAIN I WILL KNOW
TO TERMS OF THE ONGOING CONCERN
ABOUT YOU KNOW THE SHIFT IN THE
PAYMENT RESTART. DOT MAY BE THE
CASE YES THERE HAVE BEEN
MULTIPLE RUN SHORT TERM
EXTENSIONS OF THE PAYMENT POLICY
BUT THE. P. S. L. F. WE'VE- THAT
IS STATUTORY THAT EXPIRES IN
OCTOBER. THIRTY AND THEY CELL.
OF PUBLIC SIR. HERE AROUND THIS.
THAT MAY ACTUALLY NOW. L. TO GET
A- CRY TOWARD PUBLIC SERVICE
LOAN FORGIVENESS WHICH IS A HUGE
BENEFIT- AND SO THEY DO NEED TO
TAKE ACTION BEFORE. OCTOBER
THIRTY FIRST THE DEADLINE WILL
NOT MOVE I HOPE THAT IS HELPFUL.
YEAH WE ARE ASKING FOR IT. THE
REQUEST IS FOR TEN MILLION
DOLLARS THE MAJORITY OF IT GOES
TO MARKETING. LESS THAN HALF OF
IT GOES TO ACTUAL STUDENT
BORROWER ASSISTANCE GRANTS. AND
THEN NOT EVEN A SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
CONSUMER SERVICES AND MOST OF
WHAT YOU TALKED ABOUT. WHERE IS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
CONSUMER SUPPORT. SO THE NUMBER
SIMILAR OUT OF WHACK TO ME. A
MANAGER I CAN THINK THAT THAT
WOULD CONNECT TO CRYSTALS CHIEF
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER- THE WITH
THE- IF THIS BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL IS APPROVED AS PART OF
THE BUDGET THE FUNDS BECOME
AVAILABLE ON JULY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND I THINK WE-
SCHEDULE THE MONEY- A BIG TEND
TO- ADVERTISING AND-
COMMUNICATIONS ANOTHER CHUNK TO-
TO NONPROFITS WHERE WE WOULD
GIVE DIRECT GRANTS TO NONPROFITS
TO HELP STUDENT LOAN BORROWERS
AND THEN A SMALL VERY SMALL
CHUNK TO OUR ADMINISTRATIVE
EXPENSES AND OUR HOTLINE. BASED
REALLY ON THE TIME YOU GET THESE
DEADLINES CONTINUE TO BE AUGUST
THIRTY FIRST IN OCTOBER THIRTY
FIRST OUR ABILITY. BASED ON OUR
EXPERIENCE WITH- SAMPLE THE CAL
MONEYSMART GRANT PROGRAMS CENTER
BRADFORDS BUILDING WITH OFF
AUTHORIZED A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO
WE HAVE EXPERIENCE WITH ASKING
NONPROFITS TO APPLY FOR GRANTS
EVALUATING THOSE GRANTS TO
PULLING THE MONEY INTO THE FIELD
AND THEN THAT THOSE NONPROFITS
ACTUALLY SERVING BORROWERS
BECAUSE OF THESE DEADLINES WE
FEEL LIKE THAT'S THE BEST A PLAN
THAT THE FUNDS BUT WE'RE HAPPY
DAY- CHAT WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ABOUT IF THE LEGISLATURE THINGS
A DIFFERENT DEPLOYMENT OF THE
FUNDS IS WARRANTED. THANK YOU
I'M GONNA TURN IT OVER TO CENTER
COME HERE DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. YES I DO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR- I TOO HAD
THE ISSUE- OR THE QUESTION IN
REGARDS TO THAT MEDIA CAMPAIGN.
WE SPEND A LOT OF MONEY HERE AT
THE STATE- DOING MEDIA OUT REACH
AND- I JUST I ALWAYS WONDER DO
WE REALLY GET THE BEST BANG FOR
OUR BUCK IS THAT THE BEST WAY
TO- TO GET. MANY GET
PARTICIPATION AND SO I STILL
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THAT- AND
BUT I BUT I GUESS THE REAL
QUESTION HERE IS- WHAT'S THE
FASTEST WAY TO GET TO STUDENTS.
TO LET THEM KNOW THAT- THAT
THERE ARE OPTIONS OUT THERE FOR
THEM SO THAT THEY CAN EITHER
REDUCE THEIR STUDENT LOAN
OBLIGATIONS OR MAKE ARRANGEMENTS
SO THAT THEY CAN. GET THEM
REFINANCED IF THAT'S IF THAT'S A
POSSIBILITY- SO I'M I'M
WONDERING IF YOU CAN TELL US- IF
YOU SEEN AN INCREASE IN THAT
COMPLAINTS- OR AN INCREASE IN
ENQUIRIES AND I GUESS AND-
ENQUIRIES ARE DIFFERENT THE
COMPLAINTS AND IF YOU- KEEP THAT
KIND OF INFORMATION IF YOU COULD
SHARE WITH US. THANK YOU SENATOR
YES INDEED WE ARE SEEING
INCREASED COMPLAINTS AND EMAIL
WE GET EMAIL INCREASE THROUGH
MULTIPLE CHANNELS SO WE'RE HAPPY
TO. CIRCLE BACK TO GET MORE
PRECISE NUMBERS BUT I CONSULTED
WITH YOU KNOW WE HAVE A PURSUANT
TO THE STUDENT OUR BILL OF
RIGHTS WHICH PASSED IN TWENTY
TWENTY. THAT CREATED AN OFFICE
OF THE STUDENT LOAN OMBUDSPERSON
SO WE HAVEN'T OMBUDSPERSON WHO
IS NOW IN CHARGE TO. SERVE AS A
CONDUIT FOR INFORMAL ENQUIRIES
AND SHE REPORTED TO ME YESTERDAY
THAT WE SIGN IN SHE SAW. I THINK
GET 83% INCREASE IN EMAIL
INCREASE JUST TO HER OFFICE. IN
THE MONTH OF APRIL COMPARED TO
THE FIRST QUARTER OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND WE BELIEVE THAT
IS IN PART DUE TO THE FACT THAT
WE HAD HOPED HOSTED AND CO
HOSTED. WEBINARS WE OFTEN. WE
PARTNER WITH. LEGAL AID
NONPROFIT OTHER GOVERNMENTAL
AGENCIES TO ENSURE THAT WERE
EXPANDING OUR COLLECTIVE REACH
TO MAKE SURE THE BARBERS KNOW
THAT WE ARE HERE. TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AND AFTER EVERY EVENT
WE RECEIVED A SPIKE AN INFLUX
INFLUX OF INCREASED JUST TO THE
OMBUDSPERSON IN ADDITION TO WE
ARE WE ARE SEEING MORE A
COMPLAINTS HERE IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AND I THINK THAT IS. A
PRODUCT OF US DO. REACH RAISING
AWARENESS USING SOCIAL MEDIA.
PROVIDING THESE EVENTS PEOPLE
NOW SEE THAT WE ARE EXPERTS WHO
ALSO HAVE A REGULATORY AUTHORITY
HERE AND AN ABILITY TO TAKE
COMPLAINTS AND STUFF WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT TREND IS GOING TO
INCREASE MONTH OVER MONTH AS WE
STEP UP OUR- EFFORTS. AND
CERTAINLY IN THE LATTER HALF OF
THIS YEAR I'M SHOULD SHOULD
MONEY BE APPROVED- WE DON'T
ANTICIPATE ON A DRUG THE BIG
INCREASE IN BOTH FORMAL
COMPLAINTS THAT GO THROUGH OUR
LICENSING PROGRAM. AS WELL AS
EMAIL INCREASED. THROUGH OUR
OMBUDSPERSON. WE'RE GETTING. A
YEAR YES ACCORDING. I JUST WANT
OTHER ARGUMENT A LITTLE BIT TO
TENDS TO BE A PART OF YOUR- SO.
OF THE DEADLINE HERE RIGHT LIFE.
AUG THIRTY FOR. OCTOBER FIRST.
THE THIS IS A- ONE TIME GENERAL
MONEY IN A REALLY SHORT WINDOW
SO THERE'S NOT REALLY AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO HIRE VERY
YOU KNOW A BUNCH OF PEOPLE TO
WORK ON THIS. THERE'S NOT REALLY
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET NONPROFIT
UNDER CONTRACT AND HAVE THEM
HIRE PEOPLE TO WORK ON THIS IN
THAT WINDOW. SO WHILE I- I THINK
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT IS AN
ADVERTISING CAMPAIGN THE BEST
USE OF THESE FUNDS AND IT WILL
IT BE SUPER EFFECTIVE. GIVEN THE
TIGHT TIME WINDOW IN THESE ARE
DEADLINES THAT THE STATE DOESN'T
CONTROL WE THINK THAT THAT IS
OUR BEST. OPTION FOR
CALIFORNIA'S BORROWERS RIGHT
THESE PEOPLE ARE SIX MONTHS OUT
OF COLLEGE ARE MORE WHO WERE IN
THAT REPAYMENT WINDOW. TO TO
ACCESS AS MUCH OF THAT PUBLIC
SERVICE LOAN FORGIVENESS OR- OR-
REPAYMENT OPTIONS TO GET THEM
ACCURATE INFORMATION IN THAT
WINDOW. WE THINK THAT'S OUR BEST
OUR BEST BET. VERY GOOD THAT'S
THAT'S VERY HELPFUL AND IT IT
THE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE A LITTLE
BIT UNUSUAL IN THAT WE DON'T WE
DON'T CARE. WE DON'T CONTROL THE
TIMELINE AND- THIS PROGRAM IS
EXTREMELY. IMPORTANT TO US. TO
STUDENTS SAID- THE FORMER
STUDENTS SAID THAT- MONEY SO I
DO I DO APPRECIATE- I. MY
QUESTION FOLLOW UP WAS GOING TO
BE FIVE- BEEN INVOLVED IN-
WEBINARS WITH- THE SMALL
BUSINESS- AGENCY AND THAT THAT'S
BEEN- THAT'S BEEN REALLY I THINK
REALLY PRODUCTIVE IN TERMS OF
GENERATING QUESTIONS TO OUR
OFFICE AS WELL AS TO- THE OFFICE
OF SMALL BUSINESS-
ADMINISTRATION AND- THOSE DON'T
COST. A LOT OF MONEY TO PRODUCE
AND I THAT'S THAT'S WHERE I WAS
GOING WITH THE QUESTION ABOUT-
AREN'T THERE WAYS FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO DO IT- THAT ENCOURAGES.
PEOPLE TO ASK QUESTIONS TO GET
ONLINE AND THEN ONCE IT'S ONLINE
THEY CAN SEE IT AT THEIR LEISURE
SO APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS AND I
DON'T HAVE ANY MORE QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
COMING YEAR I YOU KNOW I JUST
WANT TO SAY I- I HAVEN'T SEEN
THIS INFORMATION ANYWHERE AND
YOU HAVE A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
CUSTOMERS- MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE I'M SURE WHO WOULD
BE INTERESTED IN PARTNERING WITH
YOU ALL- TO HELP SHARE THIS
INFORMATION WITH THE THOUSANDS
OF YOUNG PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE IN
OUR DISTRICTS WHO. PROBABLY HAVE
STUDENT LOANS THAT THEY NEED TO
GET- REPAID SO- I KNEW THIRD
MISTER SCHULTZ DUDE CERTAINLY
KEEP MENTIONING THESE THREE
DEADLINES JULY AUGUST AND
OCTOBER AND SO I GET IT YOU WANT
THE MONEY BUT- IT MAYBE YOU
DON'T HAVE CONTROL OF THE DEAD
ENDS BUT WE DO HAVE CONTROL OF
OUTREACH MECHANISMS. THE MAKING
SURE THAT WE ARE SHARING
INFORMATION EFFECTIVELY AND IN A
WAY THAT IS TARGETED IN TO THE
CONSTITUENTS THAT NEED IT THE
MOST AND I THINK THAT'S THE
THING THAT WE ARE. THE- CARE AND
CAREFUL ABOUT BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE TO DUPLICATE EFFORTS.
AND IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO
CHASE DOLLARS WHEN YOU DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE A PLAN. AND WE
HAVE SEEN. FROM MULTIPLE OTHER
EXAMPLES OF OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
WERE NOT ALWAYS SUCCESSFUL. IN
WHO WERE REACHING OUT TO AND IN
WAYS THAT WERE YOU OUT REACHING.
TO CREDIBLE VALIDATORS OF THE
INFORMATION WHO ARE IN VARIOUS
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE WHO
CAN DO A BETTER JOB OF
CONNECTING WITH. THE CLIENTS AND
THE CUSTOMERS THAT WERE TRYING
TO REACH. SO AND ONCE AGAIN I
JUST THINK THAT THE ROOT OF THE
RATIOS FOR THE DOLLARS SEEM A
LITTLE OUT OF WHACK I MEAN. YOU
KNOW MISS MARTIN DEL YOU SAID
THAT. ONE OFF AS IT'S SEEN AN
INCREASE IN COMPLAINTS THAT
EIGHTY THREE PERCENT. AND JUST
ONE MONTH WHICH WOULD BEG THE
QUESTION OF THEN WHY THE-
ALLOCATION FOR CONSUMER SERVICES
IS THE SMALLEST. BUT WE'LL JUST
DO THE HOLD OPEN. AND WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON THE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU- THIS IS
CALIFORNIA STATE PAYROLL SYSTEM
PROJECT IS THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE HERE. YES
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PRESENT. I WILL
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS JENNIFER
IRVINE I'M THE CHIEF BUDGETS AND
ACCOUNTING WITH THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE. AS CEO IS
REQUESTING LIMITED TERM
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT CRITICAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PAYROLL SYSTEM
PROJECTS AS THE PROJECT MOVES
TOWARD SYSTEM IMPLEMENTATION THE
NEED FOR DEDICATED LEGAL
RESOURCE TO BE IMMERSED IN THE
PROJECT EFFORTS AND PROVIDE
ADVICE. EXPERT CONSULTATION AND
SUPPORT TO THE PROJECT IS
REQUIRED. THE DEDICATED BUDGET
MANAGER IS NECESSARY TO
EFFICIENTLY MANAGE THE WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH OVERSEEING THE
DEVELOPMENT ANALYSIS ALLOCATION
MONITORING AND RECORDING OF THIS
YES YES PROJECT BUDGET AND
EXPENDITURES. THE SECOND ITEM
BEFORE YOU IS A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT TO SWAP THE CENTRAL
SERVICE COST RECOVERY FUND
PORTION OF THE CS PS RESOURCES
REQUESTED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET 2100% GENERAL FUNDS. AND
WE ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- FINANCED. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PROVIDE ANY COMMENT.
THANK YOU BUT I CAN'T THIS IS
KIND OF. FINANCE NOTHING
CONTACTED BY. GREAT THANK YOU L.
A. O. WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROVIDE
ANY COMMENT. GOOD MORNING BRIAN
METZGER WITH THE L. A. O. WE
RESTATE OUR RECOMMENDATION FROM
FEBRUARY THAT THE LEGISLATURE TO
FOR CONSIDERATION OF THE EIGHTY
THREE POINT THREE MILLION NOW
ALL GENERAL FUND. IN DEVELOPMENT
IMPLEMENTATION IN FUNDING FOR
THIS PROPOSED PROJECT UNTIL
202-220-2320 FOUR THE THREE
SPRING FINANCE LETTERS PROPOSED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD
INCREASE GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES ON THIS PROJECT BY
ABOUT FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. BUDGET
PROPOSAL AT THE SAME TIME THE
UPDATED PROJECT TIMELINE
REFLECTS AT LEAST A TWO MONTH
DELAY FROM THE PROJECT TIME WHEN
THAT WAS PRESENTED IN JANUARY
WHICH MEANS LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT THAT WAS PROPOSED BY
THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD NOT
BEGIN UNTIL APRIL TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AT THE EARLIEST- INCREASE
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES ON THE
PROJECT AS WELL AS DELAYED
LEGISLATIVE REVIEW OF THE
PROJECT. PLAN HEIGHTENS OUR
CONCERNS FROM FEBRUARY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DOES NOT HAVE THE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE PROJECT IT
NEEDS TO APPROVE DEVELOPMENT
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING AND THAT
THE ASSUME PROJECT TIME LINE
REMAINS LIKELY UNREALISTIC AND
THAT THE TIMELINE LIMITS
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT. I'M
CONSISTENT WITH THIS
RECOMMENDATION WE ALSO RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE DEFERRED
CONSIDERATION OF ANY POSSIBLE
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
FUNDS. FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
DISCOUNT TO INTEGRATE THE
PAYROLL SYSTEM AND FISCALE- THE
EXTENT OF THE INTEGRATION
BETWEEN THESE TWO SYSTEMS WILL
DEPEND ON THE SYSTEM GREATER.
THAT IS SELECTED FOR THE S. P.
S. PROJECTS AND SO WITHOUT THIS
INFORMATION THE DEPARTMENT-
SYSTEM. I'M SORRY CAN YOU YOU
RESTATE- FROZE. AND YOU JUST NOW
I CAN HEAR YOU NOW BUDGET ARM
WRESTLING LAST SO JUST RESTATE
THAT FOR THE RECORD I APOLOGIZE-
COLLEGE EYES. UNLESS YOU DID IT.
CONSISTENT WITH OUR-
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE PAYROLL
SYSTEM- WE ALSO RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE DEFERRED ITS
CONSIDERATION OF ANY POSSIBLE
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
FUNDING FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FIFTH SCALP TO INTEGRATE FISCALE
WITH THE STATE CABLE SYSTEM- HOW
THESE TWO SYSTEMS WILL BE
INTEGRATED WILL DEPEND. ON THE
SYSTEM INTEGRATOR VENDOR THAT IS
SELECTED FOR THE PAYROLL SYSTEM
PROJECT AND SO WITHOUT THIS
INFORMATION THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING FUNDING WITHOUT
KNOWING FULLY HOW INTEGRATED THE
TWO SYSTEMS WILL BECOME. AND SO
WE THINK THAT'S FUNDING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO BEGIN ITS PLANNING
EFFORTS IN THE BUDGET YEAR ARE
REASONABLE SO IT'S ABOUT HALF OF
THEIR REQUEST BUT THE REMAINING
FUNDING WE BELIEVE SHOULD BE
DEFERRED UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR. AND FINALLY
WE REYES NO SPECIFIC CONCERNS
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION- BUT IT
MINISTRY TO POSITIONS THAT WERE
REQUESTED BY THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT- WILL NOW
OPEN THE DISCUSSION TO QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR KABIR DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. I DO WELL I IT'S MORE
A COMMENT AND THEN THE QUESTION
I THINK- I'M- VERY SENSITIVE TO
IT CHECKS- IT TO DO PREPARATORY
WORK WHICH IS USUALLY THAT
CHANGE MANAGEMENT. PART OF THE
OF THE PROGRAM IF YOU DON'T DO
IT THEN WHAT HAPPENS IS YOU JUST
REPRODUCE WHATEVER THE PROBLEMS
WERE WITH THE ORIGINAL-
TECHNOLOGY AND- AND YOU'RE
YOU'RE PLAYING CATCH UP. TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE IT
BETTER- WHEN YOU DIDN'T PLAN
FROM THE BEGINNING SO I'M VERY
SENSITIVE TO THE- CONCERNED
ABOUT- HAVING THE INFORMATION
YOU NEED. AND HAVE IT BE
IDENTIFIED AS PART OF THE
SOLUTION WHEN YOU'RE PICKING THE
VENDOR- IN ORDER TO THEN BE ABLE
TO UTILIZE THAT WHEN YOU'RE
MOVING INTO INTO FISCAL I FISCAL
IS NOT AN EASY TRANSITION FOR
DEPARTMENTS TO. TO MAKE IT STICK
AND I THINK FOR THEM WE THOUGHT
IT WAS GONNA TAKE- SO I'M I'M
SENSITIVE TO THAT AND I- I THINK
IT'S A IT'S A GOOD
RECOMMENDATION WHICH IS TO SPLIT
THESE INTO. DIFFERENT PIECES AND
WE CAN TAKE THEM UP AT A
DIFFERENT TIME TO CREATE CREATE
THE INFORMATION. THANK YOU
SENATOR KABIRU YEAH I TO THINK
IT'S M. WISER TO ALREADY HAVE
YOUR VENDOR IDENTIFIED OR AT
LEAST. A SMALLER POOL OF
POTENTIAL VENDORS THAT HAVE THE
STRINGS THAT ARE NECESSARY TO
MAKE THIS KIND OF TRANSFER
SUCCESSFUL. AND MUCH MORE
STREAMLINED AND WE'VE SEEN SO
MANY EXAMPLES OF- PROCUREMENTS
THAT HAPPEN AND IT'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A CUSTOMIZED
PROGRAM AND SOMETHING OFF THE
SHELF AND THEN THINGS GO
SIDEWAYS AND THIS SEEMS LIKE
SOMETHING WHERE YOU WANT TO HAVE
YEAR. HE'S CROSSED IN YOUR EYES
DOTTED BEFORE YOU GET THE MONEY-
SO THIS IS GOING TO BE A HOLD
OPEN ITEM THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE ON YOUTH
THANK YOU YES TO ISSUE FORTY.
DEPARTMENTAL ONBOARDING IN
CALIFORNIA STATE PAYROLL SYSTEM
ADJUSTMENT AND CONSULTANT
TRANSITIONING CONSULTANT
WORKLOAD TO STATE STAFF THAT WAS
A LONG SENTENCE. THE PAST
DISCOUNT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENTS. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATOR CURRIER
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. MY
NAME IS MERRIAM BARCELONA
ENGINEER NOW AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE FINANCIAL
INFORMATION SYSTEM FOR
CALIFORNIA BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY- WE HAD THREE TOTAL
REQUESTS ONE IS ON- THE ONLY AND
SO WE DO THANK YOU FOR THAT OUR
TOTAL REQUESTED FOR THIRTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME FINDING
FIFTEEN POINT TWO MILLION ON
TELLING. AND SIXTY FOR PERMANENT
POSITIONS ACROSS THREE DIFFERENT
SPRING WATERS LIKE I SAID THE
FIRST ONE IS ON THE ONLY WITH
THE INFORMATION SECURITY AND
INTERNAL CONTROLS AND COMPLIANCE
COMPONENT AND THE SECOND TWO ARE
BEFORE YOU- AT THE MOMENT
TRANSITIONING SOME OF OUR
CONSULTANT WORKLOAD- AND ARE.
FROM CONTRACTORS TO STATE STAFF
PROPER AND AS YOU ARE AWARE WE
HAVE HAD A SYSTEM INTEGRATOR AND
EXTRA TEN YEARS THAT CONTRACT IS
COMING TO A CLOSE- IT. CEASES TO
EXIST NON JEWS ARE ON JUNE
THIRTIETH AND- OVER THE COURSE
OF THAT A TEN YEAR WE HAVE BEEN
TRANSITIONING WORKLOAD FROM THE
CONTRACTORS. TO- TO OUR STATE
RESOURCES. BEYOND HAVE ALSO BEEN
AT THIS TIME- GATHERING A LIST
OF ADDITIONAL ENHANCEMENTS THE
DEPARTMENTS AND OUR PARTNERS
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IN THE SYSTEM
AND SO THEY SAY IBCP OR THE
SPRING FINANCE LETTER WOULD.
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE ISSUES AND
REQUESTS AND THEN THE THIRD
COMPONENT IS THE DEPARTMENTAL
ONBOARDING AND B. AND- OF THE
TWO OF THE TEN DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS AND STARTING THE
WORK ON THE THIRD. AND THAT TEN
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS AS YOU
WILL RECALL THERE ARE WHEN THE
SYSTEM WAS DEVELOPED AND
DEPLOYED THERE WERE TEN
DEPARTMENTS THAT ALREADY HAD
MODERN ERP SYSTEMS. AND IT WAS
DETERMINED THAT THEY WOULD NOT
COME ON TO THE FISCAL SYSTEM
UNTIL IT WAS THE END OF THE
USEFUL LIFE. OF THEIR SYSTEMS
TWO OF THOSE ARE ON EXPIRING NOW
IN A READY TO TRANSITION ON THIS
GALLON THAT'S THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSFER RIGHT. THAT TECHNOLOGY
SORRY THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY TO KEEP AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION AND WE WILL BE
STARTING THE WORK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION. OR KNOWN AS
CALTRANS- AND THEN THE FINAL TO.
OF AS MENTIONED IN THE PREVIOUS
ITEM. M. IS FOR US TO PARTNER
WITH THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN RESOURCES IN
THE- CONNECTION OF THEIR PAYROLL
SYSTEM TO OUR ACCOUNTING SYSTEM
AS YOU KNOW. ONE OF THE LARGEST
ACCOUNTING ITEMS FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THE SINGLE LARGEST
EXPENDITURE ITEM FOR THE STATE
IS OF COURSE THE D. THE PAYROLL
ITEMS THAT COME THROUGH. SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH-
WITH THEM ON THAT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD BUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
GREAT THANK YOU FOR THAT SO NOW-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO COMMENT. VETERAN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU L. A. O. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO COMMENT. PRIME MINISTER
L. A. O. OUR ANALYSIS OF
FISCALES SPRING FINANCE LETTERS
IS INCLUDED IN TODAY'S AGENDA SO
WE'LL KEEP OUR COMMENTS BRIEF-
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL HAVE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
THIS SCALE OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
MONTHS. STARTING IN EARNEST
LATER THIS MONTH- IN THESE
DISCUSSIONS WILL LEAD TO
IMPORTANT DECISIONS ABOUT- YOU
KNOW THE FUTURE FISCAL AND WILL-
DECIDE FOR EXAMPLE IF AND WHEN
FISCAL WILL BECOME THE STATE'S
BOOK OF RECORD. SO THESE
DECISIONS THAT ARE MADEBY THE
ADMINISTRATION MUST BE CLEARLY
COMMUNICATED TO THE LEGISLATURE-TO INFORM ITS- DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
FUTURE BUDGET ACTIONS AS WELL AS
POLICY DIRECTION- WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE ATOP SOME
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT LANGUAGE
HERE. TO MAKE SURE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE ARE CLEAR ON WHAT
WORK REMAINS TO BE DONE ON THE
PROJECT- WHAT DISAGREEMENTS
THERE ARE BETWEEN THE PROJECT
PARTNERS THAT MUST BE ADDRESSED
AS WELL AS WHAT DECISIONS MUST
BE MADE TO FINISH THE PROJECT AS
ENVISIONED- IN TO ENSURE THAT
THIS REPORT IS DELIVERED TO THE
LEGISLATURE BY A CERTAIN DATE-
THE LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO ADOPT
SOME PROVISIONAL BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WITHHOLD SOME
AMOUNT OF FUNDING- UNTIL THE
REPORT IS SUBMITTED. AND WE
WOULD KNOW. THE JUST THAT.
YESTERDAY BUDGET SUB HER THESE
FINE LETTERS. AND ADOPTED SOME.
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
CONTAINS A NUMBER OF ELEMENTS.
INCLUDING SOME FROM OUR ANALYSIS
IN THE AGENDA. AS WELL AS
PROVISIONAL BY BILL LANGUAGE TO
ALLOW ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
FISCAL TWO ON BOARD- ADDITIONAL
DEPARTMENTS IF POSSIBLE- THANK
YOU HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RIGHT NOW
WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE DISCUSSION
OF QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR COPY OR DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS- I I'M NOT.
I'M NOT SURE I BUY MY THIS IS A
HOLD OPEN ITEM SO YES ALTHOUGH
IT IT IS- I THINK IT IS- THE
FISCAL HAS- HAS ACHIEVED LOT
OF THE GOALS THAT WERE SET UP
INITIALLY AND THAT'S ALWAYS A
GOOD THING WHEN YOU'RE DOING AT-
THE PROJECT. AS LARGEST FISCAL-
I THINK IT TOOK LONGER THAN WE
THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO TAKE
BUT- RIGHT RIGHT HERE GOOD
REPORTS. IT'S A IT'S A
COMPLICATED PROCESS TO MOVE OVER
DEPARTMENTS FROM THEIR OWN
SYSTEMS TO A TO A MASTER SYSTEM
AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT- TO BE ABLE TO
FINALIZE IT AND- AND HAVE THE
HABIT. HAVE THERE BE A BOOK OF
RECORD I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TIME. I'VE HEARD OVER
AND OVER AGAIN THAT THE STATE.
FARM HASN'T FINISHED ITS ITS
REPORTING- FOR SOME OF THE
FISCAL YEARS. BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
MADE THE TRANSITION FOR TEST FOR
SOME OF THE DEPARTMENTS AND- IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT THE PUBLIC
HAVE CONFIDENCE. THAT WE ARE
SPENDING THE MONEY THE WAY THAT
WE SAY WE'RE GOING TO SPEND IT
AND THAT WE'RE CLOSING OUT-
COUNTS AS WE- AS WE END THE YEAR
AND WE SAY. WE'RE WE'RE
PHYSICALLY SO WE'RE FISCALLY
SOLVENT AND SO- WE NEED TO WE
NEED TO GET THERE SO THAT- SO
THAT WE- WE CAN ASSURE THE
PUBLIC THAT WE'RE SPENDING THE
MONEY THE WAY THAT WE SAY AND
THAT THE DEPARTMENTS ARE
MANAGING IN IT IN AN EFFICIENT
WAY SO APPRECIATE THAT THE
COMMENTS AND I APPRECIATE. THE
WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE- ON FISCO
I KNOW IT IT IS BEEN- MORE
DIFFICULT THAN I THINK ANY OF US
THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO BE BAD-
IT LOOKS LIKE WE'RE FINALLY
GETTING TO THE END AND THAT'S A
GOOD THING. THANK YOU SENATOR
KABIR I HAVE NO QUESTIONS THIS
IS A HOLD OPEN ITEMS I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL- SO THAT ACTUALLY
CONCLUDES PART A OF THE AGENDA.
WE'VE DONE ALL OF OUR DISCUSSION
ONLY FOR PART A WE'RE GOING TO
DO VOTE ONLY FOR PART EIGHT
AFTER WE HAVE DONE DISCUSSION
FOR PART B. AND AFTER WE HAVE
TAKEN PUBLIC COMMENT. SO THAT
GIVES OUR MEMBERS TIME TO.
SHUFFLE ON OVER HERE- SO NOW
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO PART
B. OF THE AGENDA AND ONCE AGAIN
THIS IS ON DISCUSSION ONLY THE
FIRST ISSUE FOR DISCUSSION IS
ISSUE. EIGHT ON HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSALS- THE L.
A. O. WILL BE PRESENTING THIS
ITEM. L. A. WOULD YOU PLEASE
PRESENT. GOOD MORNING KAREN
SENATORS I KNEW THIS MORE NOT
LESS. BUT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. COMMITTEE
STAFF HAVE ASKED US TO SUMMARIZE
THE SENATE MAJORITY PROPOSAL FOR
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS WHICH
AUGMENTS THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PLAN. THE GOVERNOR'S TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE BUDGET
INCLUDES A TOTAL OF FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS FOR HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. OVER TWO YEARS FOR
A VARIETY OF NEW AND EXISTING
PROGRAMS. WE THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES TO BILLION IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND OVER TWO YEARS. TO
EXPAND HOUSING DEVELOPMENT MEANT
THAT THE SYSTEM DEVELOPMENT THAT
REDUCES VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
AND LOWERS GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. TO EXPAND DEVELOPMENT
ON ITS STATE ACCESS THAT WEBSITE
. ADAPTIVE REUSE OF EXISTING
PROPERTIES CONTINUE THE STATE
LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM AND REFORM THE WAY THE
STATE SUPPORTS AND REGULATES
MOBILE HOMES. THE GOVERNOR ALSO
PROPOSES TO BILLION IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND OVER TWO YEARS THAT
IS INTENDED TO ADDRESS IN NEAR
TERM HOMELESSNESS NEEDS WELL
PREVIOUSLY AUTHORIZED FUNDING
FOR HOMELESSNESS COMES ONLINE.
SPECIFICALLY THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES ONE POINT FIVE. BILLION
DOLLARS FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WHICH FUNDING INTENDED TO
ADDRESS IMMEDIATE HOUSING AND
TREATMENT NEEDS FOR PEOPLE WITH
COMPLEX BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS AND FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THE INCOMING
RESOLUTION GRANT PROGRAM. FINAL
NEED THE TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES BASELINE
FUNDING. OF ONE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR HALF THE HOMELESS HOUSING
ASSISTANCE AND PREVENTION
PROGRAM AND ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR PROJECT
HUNKY THIS FUNDING WAS AGREED TO
AS PART OF THE TO YOUR
HOMELESSNESS PACKAGE PROVIDED IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET. THE AGENDA DEVELOPED BY
COMMITTEE STAFFER TODAY'S
HEARING NOTES THAT WHILE IT YOU
. IS THE ADMINISTER PROPOSALS
FOR HOUSING HOMELESSNESS AS
PROBABLY REASONABLE THERE AREAS
WHERE. ACTION BE NECESSARY. WE
THE SENATE MUCH PROPOSAL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FOR HOUSING WHO. AS
FOLLOWS. FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR THE MULTI HOUSING PROGRAM
THE STATE'S FLAGSHIP MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING PROGRAM. FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE HOUSING
ACCELERATOR PROGRAM. WHICH FUNDS
PROJECTS THAT ARE SHOVEL READY
BUT HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO ACCESS
LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM. THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FOR CALHOUN WHICH
SUPPORTS FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS.
TWO HUNDRED MILLION FOR DOWN
PAYMENT ASSISTANCE ONE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR FARMWORKER HOUSING.
FIFTY MILLION TO HELP FINANCE
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS AND ONE
MILLION FOR THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
FOR ALL PROGRAM THE NEW
REVOLVING FUND PROGRAM FOR FIRST
TIME HOME BUYERS WHICH IS THE
SUBJECT OF THE NEXT ITEM ON YOUR
AGENDA TODAY. FINALLY THE SENATE
MAJORITY PLAN INCLUDES THREE
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS
IN ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
HOMELESSNESS. THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING WOULD BE USED FOR
PROJECT HOME KEY AND CAST
MEMBERS. SOLUTIONS PROGRAMS AND
FOR. THIS CONCLUDES OUR
DESCRIPTION OF THE SENATE
MAJORITY HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PLAN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FINANCE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PROVIDE ANY COMMENT. RIDLEY
THOMPSON DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE ANY COMMENT. I SEE NO
ONE I HEAR NO ONE. THERE MUST BE
NO ONE. ALL RIGHT I'M GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR COMING YEAR-
DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. THEY
SEEM TO BE TALKING A LOT TODAY
BUT NOT ASKING QUESTIONS. THIS
REALLY IS THE SENATE PROPOSAL-
ON HOUSING AND- AND HOMELESSNESS
AND SO AYE AYE I WANNA. WANNA
CALL OUT THAT- WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE'S BEEN WORKING VERY
CAREFULLY AND CLOSELY WITH THE
GOVERNOR TO. BOB PUT AN EMPHASIS
ON THE NEED FOR MORE HOUSING AND
IN PARTICULAR ON AREAS WHERE- WE
CAN REALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE
AND- HOUSING AND THE LACK OF
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES. IS
AFFECTING EVERY SINGLE
COMMUNITY. AND I DON'T THINK WE
GET THE CREDIT. FOR PUTTING UP
THE RESOURCES TO IT TO TRY TO
GET PEOPLE INTO HOUSING AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND I SAY
THAT BECAUSE- IN MY REGION. WHEN
COMMUNITY CELEBRATE THEIR
OPENING AT. AM ONE OF THE MOTELS
AND CONVERTING IT TO HOUSING
IT'S THE CITY AND THE COUNTY
THAT GET TOGETHER THAT SHE
KANSEN THEY TAKE PICTURES AND
THEY NEVER THEY NEVER MENTION
THAT IS STATE FUNDING THAT MAKES
THIS POSSIBLE SO I. I'M HERE TO
SAY YOU KNOW WHAT YOU WOULD NEED
IN IT WITHOUT THE STATE AND- WE
ARE PARTNERS IN THIS AND WANT TO
CONTINUE TO BE PARTNERS AND WHAT
I'M REALLY PROUD OF IS THAT.
THERE'S A REAL NEED FOR A FIRST
TIME HOME BUYER PROGRAM. AND-
WE'VE- MADE SURE THAT THERE ARE
RESOURCES SO THAT WE CAN HELP
PEOPLE WHO DESPERATELY WANT TO
BUY THEIR FIRST HOME TO GET
INTO- TO GET INTO IT THEIR OWN
HOME IT'S THE BEST WAY TO BUILD
pWEALTH AND SO THE MORE THAT WE
CAN. WE CAN FOCUS ON THAT I
THINK THAT'S A REALLY GOOD THING
SO THERE'S A LITTLE BIT. IN
EVERY SINGLE CATEGORY BECAUSE
WHAT WE'VE HEARD IS THAT ALL OF
THAT ALL OF THE FUNDS ARE
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND SO I'M I'M
REALLY PROUD OF THIS- MONEY HERE
IT'S NOT AN AFRICAN IT'LL NEVER
BE ENOUGH BUT- WE'VE WE'VE SAID
IT IS A PRIORITY AND IT'S
REFLECTED HERE AND I WANT TO-
I'M HOPING THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
GOVERNOR ARE- IN SUPPORTIVE. OF
THIS AND I LOOK FORWARD TO.
BEING ABLE TO GO BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY SINCE SAY THERE ARE
RESOURCES- AND- WE HEARD YOU
AND- AND WE ARE YOUR PARTNER SO.
THAT STILL HAVE TO SAY NO
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SENATOR
CABALLERO I ALSO DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I DO THINK. THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT TO HAVE A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT BUCKETS FOR FUNDING
BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY. KINDS OF
SOLUTIONS. TO THE ISSUES OF
HOMELESSNESS IN UNAFFORDABILITY.
AND THE SOLUTIONS MAY LOOK
DIFFERENT DEPENDING ON WHAT PART
OF THE STATE YOU LIVE IN- AND
HOW YOU ARE ABLE TO ACCESS
RESOURCES. AND THE CAPACITY OF
THE PARTNERS THAT THE STATE HAS-
TO WORK WITH. ACROSS ACROSS THE
STATE SO. I APPLAUD THE FACT
THAT THOUGHT WAS GIVEN INTO HOW
WE CAN BE DIVERSE- IN OUR
ABILITIES TO SUPPORT. THIS
REALLY CRITICAL. CRISIS AND I TO
AGREE SENATE A COUPLE YEAR
OFTENTIMES. THE STATE DOESN'T
GET ANY LOVE EVEN WHEN WE'RE
WRITING CHECKS IN AND I'M ALL
OVER THE PLACE SO. WE WANT SOME
LOVE OKAY- THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO HOLD OPEN
AND WE ARE NOW MOVING ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TE. A DIVISION OF
STATE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
BUDGET ADJUSTMENTS IN H. C. D.
WOULD YOU. ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA
DREAM FOR ALL FIRST TIME IT WAS
A TEST THAT WAS A TEST WE'RE NOW
MOVING THE CALIFORNIA DREAM FOR
ALL FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS
PROGRAM- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT. I SEE YOU THINKING THIS
A GREAT MISS LORD THIS. THANK
YOU INTO THE SMALLEST OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
COMMITTEE STUFF IS ALSO ASKING
TO PRESENT THIS ITEM THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
INCLUDES THREE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE TO STUDY AND
PLAN A STATE FUNDED FIRST TIME
HOME BUYER PROGRAM WHICH WOULD
BE KNOWN AS A CALIFORNIA DREAM
FOR ALL FIRST TIME HOME BUYER
PROGRAM. TREASURE'S OFFICE
SUBSEQUENTLY CONTRACTED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FORWARD TO STUDY THIS
ISSUE IN THE REPORT IS
SUMMARIZED IN THE AGENDA THE
SENATE MAJORITY PLAN INCLUDES
ONE BILLION DOLLARS FOR FROM THE
GENERAL FUND FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM FOR ALL TWENTY THREE ALONG
WITH ONGOING FUNDING FOR PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. THE BUDGET
PLAN ENVISIONS INTERNAL MARIN IN
FUTURE YEARS TO PROVIDE A ONE
BILLION PER YEAR FOR A FULL TEN
YEAR PERIOD AFTER THAT TIME THE
REVOLVING NATURE OF THE PROGRAM
WOULD BE ABLE TO PROGRAM TO
CONTINUE WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
STATE RESOURCES OTHER THAN-
ANNUAL ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS THAT
CONCLUDES OUR BRIEF DESCRIPTION
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE OTHERS
SPEAKERS TO PROVIDE MORE DETAIL
ABOUT THE REPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
THE OTHERS SPEAKERS- I DIDN'T
YOURSELF SO THAT WE CAN FROM
YOU. WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO NEXT I
THINK I SEE MISTER SHADE FOR.
READY I'M SURE THAT AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEES IS JIM
SHIVERED STATE TREASURER I KEEP
MY COMMENTS BRIEF BUT JUST TO
GIVE YOU SOME BACKGROUND ON THE
STUDY THAT'S BEING PERFORMED
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED AB
ONE FORTY IF PROVIDED FUNDS FOR
A STUDY TO BE UNDERTAKEN BY THE
STATE TREASURER IN CONSULTATION
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCY AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. THE STUDY
WAS TO DEVELOP A FRAMEWORK FOR
THE CONCEPTUAL DREAMS CALIFORNIA
DREAM FOR ALL PROGRAM. THE
ENABLING LEGISLATION PROVIDES AT
THE STUDY MUST BE SUBMITTED TO
THE LEGISLATURE NO LATER THAN
ONE YEAR AFTER THE EFFECTIVE
DATE. IN OCTOBER OF TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE THE TREASURER
RELEASED A DETAILED RFP
ENCOMPASSING THOSE LEGISLATIVE
GOALS AND THE INTENT OF AB ONE
FORTY. AND SOUGHT SPECIFIC
DETAILED PROPOSALS FROM
QUALIFIED CONSULTANTS
EXPERIENCED IN THE DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF HOUSING
FINANCE OR MORTGAGE BANKING
PROGAMS. AFTER AN EXTENSIVE
SOLICITATION AND EVALUATION OF
THOSE RESPONSES A CONSORTIUM LED
BY CALIFORNIA FORWARD WAS
SELECTED TO PERFORM THE STUDY.
THE INVASION PROGRAM
CONTEMPLATES MAKING HOME
OWNERSHIP MORE AFFORDABLE BY
REDUCING THE INITIAL OUT OF
POCKET COSTS OF SUCH OWNERSHIP
FOR LOWER AND MODERATE INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. PLANNERS ALSO
INTENDED TO ENABLE AND ENCOURAGE
HOMEBUILDERS TO SELL MORE NEW
ENTRY LEVEL PHONES AT PRICES
THAT ARE MORE ATTAINABLE BY
PURCHASERS IN THIS DEMOGRAPHIC.
THE PROGRAM WOULD ESTABLISH A
STATE SPONSORED CALIFORNIA DREAM
FOR ALL FUND WHICH WOULD COVER A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
INITIAL OUT OF POCKET COSTS OF
THE HOME PURCHASE IN EXCHANGE
FOR A PARTIAL UNDERSTOOD
OWNERSHIP STAKE IN THE HOME. THE
SILENT PARTNER OWNERSHIP WITHIN
BENEFICIALLY OWN A MINORITY
SHARE OF THE HALL THIS APPROACH
IS FREQUENTLY REFERRED TO AS A
SHARED APPRECIATION MORTGAGE. A
SHARED APPRECIATION MORTGAGES
GENERALLY STRUCTURED AS A GOOD
FOR MOM ON WHICH NO PAYMENTS ARE
DUE UNTIL THE HOME IS SOLD TO
THE NEXT BUYER OR IN SOME CASES
THE FIRST MORTGAGES REFINANCE.
AND AT THAT TIME THE SUBSIDY
MUST BE REPAID ALONG WITH THE
AGREED UPON SHARE OF
APPRECIATION. THROUGH THIS
APPROACH LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS COULD BENEFIT FROM
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME
HOMEOWNERS AND BUILD EQUITY.
SPECIFICALLY THE CONTRACTOR
RISING FROM THE R. F. P.
REQUIRES THE SELECTED A VENDOR
TO DEVELOP A FRAMEWORK PROPOSAL
THAT WOULD DEMONSTRATE CLEARLY
HOW I WOULD EXPAND THE
AVAILABILITY OF ENTRY LEVEL
HOUSING STOCK. FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS AND TO. FURTHER THAT
DISCUSSION AND GIVE YOU AN
UPDATE ON PROGRESS I WILL NOW
TURN TO MICHAEL WEINBERG THE
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER
CALIFORNIA WHO IS THE PRIME
CONTRACTOR ON THIS ENGAGEMENT.
GREAT THANK YOU CALIFORNIA COURT
WORK AND THEN I MY UNDERSTANDING
. MICA IS THAT YOU HAVE- SLIDES
. ZERO FIVE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND NO I AM NOT THE NOT
THE CEO CALIFORNIA. HARD JOB. I
DO HAVE SOME SLIDES. I HOPE TO
BE ABLE TO GO TO THIS
PRESENTATION PRETTY QUICKLY
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
pTO LANDSCAPING AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS SO-
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY WHEN IS
MICHAEL WEINBERG I'M CEO OF
CALIFORNIA FORWARD. MOVEMENT TO
MAKE CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND
GOVERNMENT WORK FOR EVERYONE
EACH YEAR WE HOST THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMIC SUMMIT IN HOUSING AND
HOMEOWNERSHIP HAS BEEN AREA
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON FOR YEARS
BEEN VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP OF PRESIDENT PRO TEM
ATKINS AND CENTER COPY GYRO. AND
MANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THIS WORK AND AS
SUCH WE WERE VERY GRATEFUL TO BE
CHOSEN BY THE STATE TREASURER'S
OFFICE FOR THIS PROJECT AND IT'S
BEEN A DELIGHT TO WORK WITH
TREASURE MINOR STAFF ON IT
GREATLY APPRECIATED THE
OPPORTUNITY AS WELL TO WORK WITH
MANY MEMBERS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION A. B. C. S. H. H.
C. D. N. ESPECIALLY COLLEGE
AFRAID TO REFINE AND IMPROVE
THIS PROPOSAL. WE WERE ALSO VERY
LUCKY TO WORK WITH AN AMAZING
TEAM ON THIS PROJECT AND YOU MAY
BE HEARING FROM SOME OF THE
PRINCIPLES OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS DURING THE
QUESTION AND ANSWER PERIOD
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BUILDERS A
JOURNEY ADVISORS AND CSG
ADVISORS HAVE BEEN ABSOLUTE
DREAM TEAM FOR THIS WORK
COMBINING POLICY KNOWLEDGE AND
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE IN A WAY
THAT WAS BEEN REALLY FANTASTIC
TO WORK WITH. OKAY SO I KNOW
THAT WE ALL UNDERSTAND THE
GRAVITY OF THE SITUATION SO THIS
IS THE ONLY SLIDE THAT I WILL
SPEND TO QUOTE ADMIRING THE
PROBLEM NOW BUT I WANT TO CALL
OUT TWO THINGS IN. PARTICULAR
FIRST. YOU ARE STRUGGLING
HOUSING. FALL ACROSS THE STATE.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE. THAT
THE STATE HOMEOWNER. ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM SERVE PEOPLE IN ALL
PARTS OF THE STATE INCLUDING IN
ITS HIGH COST AREAS. THE BAY
AREA IN PARTICULAR IS SEEN IT'S
MEDIAN HOUSING PRICE RISE THREE
TIMES HIGHER. THAN SOME OTHER
AREAS OF THE STATE SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN. SAKIN IT IS DIFFICULT
TO PROMOTE HOMEOWNERSHIP WITHOUT
HOMES FOR PEOPLE TO OWN. SO I
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THE
LEGISLATURE IS DOING TO WORK ON
INCREASING THE SUPPLY OF HOUSING
. THE RACIAL DISPARITIES IN
HOMEOWNERSHIP ARE TRULY
STRIKING. AS SUCH WE CANNOT WAIT
UNTIL MORE HOUSING IS BUILT FOR
THESE COMMUNITIES TO BEGIN TO
BUILD THE GENERATIONAL WEALTH
THAT THEY WERE LOCKED OUT OF IN
DEEPLY DESERVE. SO IN ADDITION
FOR TO A PROGRAM THAT IS GOING
TO WORK IN ALL PARTS OF THE
STATE WE NEED A PROGRAM THAT IS
GOING TO PROVIDE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF ASSISTANCE FOR
HOMEOWNERS ESPECIALLY IN THE
STATE'S BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES. ALRIGHT SO SINCE
THIS IS A BRIEF PRESENTATION AND
NOT A LONG SEMINAR THERE ARE A
VARIETY OF WAYS IN WHICH YOU CAN
HELP ACHIEVE HOMEOWNERSHIP AND I
DON'T HAVE TIME TO REVIEW THEM
ALL IN DETAIL THIS MORNING. WHAT
I WANT TO CALL OUT HERE IS THAT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS
OTHER AGENCIES AT THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL. RAFIC AND
THOROUGHLY DESERVING OF YOUR
SUPPORT AND WE WERE DELIGHTED TO
SEE ALLOCATIONS TO THOSE
PROGRAMS MADE IN THE SENATE'S
BUG BUDGET PACKAGE AND WE
SUPPORT THEM ENTIRELY. THE
PROGRAM I'M GONNA BE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
FOR ALL PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO
COMPLEMENT THESE PROGRAMS WITH A
PARTICULAR APPROACH THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY TAILORED TO THE
HOMEOWNERSHIP CHALLENGES THAT WE
ARE NOT ADDRESSING TO OUR
EXISTING PROGRAMS. AND IT IS
DESIGNED TO DO IT ON A SCALE
THEY WILL HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL
IMPACT ON RACIAL AND ECONOMIC
EQUITY IN THE STATE. THE MAIN
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THIS AND THE
OTHER PROGRAMS IS THE DOWN
PAYMENT ASSISTANCE COMES OUT OF
REPAYING IT COMES OUT OF THE
APPRECIATION OF THE HOME. THIS
IS DIFFERENT FROM A FORGIVABLE
LOAN THAT IS PAID FOR ALMOST
ENTIRELY BY THE PUBLIC SECTOR.
AND HENCE DOESN'T RECYCLE MUCH
OF THE MONEY TO HELP NEW
HOMEOWNERS BECAUSE KEEP IN MIND
THE STATE DOESN'T MAKE MONEY ON
THIS PROGRAM THE MONEY THAT THE
STATE GETS BACK FROM SHARED
APPRECIATION GETS USED TO HELP
ADDITIONAL HOMEOWNERS AND THAT'S
WHY THIS IS A REVOLVING
INVESTMENT FUND. INSTEAD OF A
ONE TIME PROGRAM. ALSO DIFFERENT
FROM MORE CONVENTIONAL FIXED
INTEREST SECOND LOANS THAT ARE
PAID FOR BY THE HOMEOWNER.
REFINANCING OR SALE. TO BE CLEAR
BOTH OF THESE OTHER TYPES OF
PROGRAMS ARE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
AND USEFUL BUT THEY DO NOT SOLVE
ALL THE CHALLENGES THAT THE
STATE HAS BEEN PROMOTED
HOMEOWNERSHIP. OKAY SO AS WE SET
OUT TO. WORK ON THIS PROJECT WE
REALLY WANTED TO HAVE A NUMBER
OF KEY GOALS IN MIND SO I'M
GONNA GO OVER THOSE GOALS AND
HOW THIS SPECIFIC PROGRAM
ADDRESS SYSTEM. FIRST WE REALLY
WANT TO PROVIDE A LARGE AMOUNT
OF DOWN PAYMENT ASSISTANCE I
TALKED ABOUT THE NEED FOR RACIAL
AND ECONOMIC EQUITY. AND WHAT WE
WANT TO DO IS PROVIDE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF ASSISTANCE
PRIEST SOMEWHAT SMALLER NUMBER
OF BORROWERS WE DON'T WANT TO
HAPPEN SPEND SO MUCH MONEY IN
THE MARKET THAT WE JUST INFLATE
THE MARKET GENERALLY. AND DON'T
ACTUALLY HELP OUT WITH- THE
SPECIFIC POPULATIONS WE WANT TO
REACH WE WANT TO SUPPORT REAL
WEALTH ACCUMULATION TIED TO HELP
BRIDGE THOSE ECONOMIC AND-
EQUITY GAPS. WE WANT TO MAXIMIZE
THE NUMBER OF HOUSEHOLDS
ASSISTED OVER TIME THROUGH
RECYCLING THE MONEY. WHICH I
TALKED ABOUT AS A KEY DIFFERENCE
WITH A FORGIVABLE LOAN PROGRAMS.
AND THEN WE WANT TO COMPLEMENT
THE EXISTING HOMEOWNERSHIP
PROGRAMS BY SERVING NEW TYPES OF
BORROWERS SO HOW DOES THIS
PROGRAM DO NOT. IT REDUCES THE
INCOME REQUIRED TO PURCHASE THE
MEDIAN PRICED HOME BY OVER
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
NINETY THOUSAND DOLLARS NOW I
WANT TO MAKE THE POINT HERE NOT
ALL HOMEOWNERS AND ESPECIALLY
NOT ALL. FIRST TIME HOMEOWNERS
FIRST GENERATION HOMEOWNERS ARE
GOING TO BE PURCHASING A MEDIAN
PRICED HOUSE IT'LL BE USING THIS
NUMBER FOR A MEDIAN PRICED HOUSE
BECAUSE THAT MIGHT BE MORE
REPRESENTATIVE OF WHAT SOME
BUYERS ARE GOING TO BE SEEING.
IN THE HIGHER COST AREAS THAT
ARE LAST SERVED BY THE STATE'S
EXISTING PROGRAMS. BUT IT LOWERS
THE DIE- THE INCOME NECESSARY
SUBSTANTIALLY WHICH IS THE GOAL
OF THE PROGRAM. SECOND THE
CREATES A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
OUR WEALTH OVER FORTY YEARS IT
WILL CREATE OVER A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS IN
BORROWER WELL. WHICH IS MORE.
THAN FIVE INDEED EXPECTS INR. I
A NUMBER OF ON INCLUDE US AND
LIST IN PRO. AND NOW AGAIN I'VE
TALKED ABOUT THE RISK BIN. IT
WAS OVER HUNDRED THOUSAND
FAMILIES OVER THIS PERIOD OF
TIME WHICH IS. AS WELL
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE THAN THIS
SIMPLE LIST INTEREST PROGRAM
BECAUSE OF THE GREATER RECYCLING
THROUGH THE APPRECIATION. IT
DOES ALL OF THIS AT A LOWER
TOTAL COST TO THE STATE AND WITH
GREATER DOWNSIDE PROTECTION FOR
THE BORROWERS ESPECIALLY BECAUSE
OF HOW WE DESIGNED THE PROGRAM.
SO I JUST HAVE A COUPLE MORE.
SLIDES TO GO THROUGH AND THEN
HAPPY TO ANSWER YOURQUESTIONS
SO HERE ARE SOME OF THE
STATISTICS THAT I'VE BEEN
MENTIONING- THIS YEAR
DEPRECIATION PROGRAM WILL
PROVIDE A 17% DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE- WE ARE COMFORTABLE
WITH THESE BORROWERS. RECEIVING
OTHER DOWN PAYMENT ASSISTANCE
FROM OTHER PROGRAMS ARE FROM
FAMILIES WE DON'T REQUIRE ANY
DOWN PAYMENT FROM THE BORROWERS
. A LOT OF RESEARCH IN THIS A-
HAS INTO THAT DOT COM YEAH IT
ISN'T AS IMPORTANT. FOR THE
HOMEOWNERS THE WONDERFUL
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT WORK DONE
BY CAN THAT. CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY BUILDERS ARE RUN BY
ADAM REALNESS HASN'T REALLY
SHOWN THAT THE KEY IS MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR SUPPORT AND
COUNSELING PRE AND POST PURCHASE
FOR THOSE BORROWERS THAT IS MUCH
MORE IMPORTANT THAN THE AMOUNT
OF KORAPUT SKIN THAT THEY HAVE
ANY GAME. CAUGHT ONE TRADE OFF
IS. SORT OF ALMOST. YOU KNOW
COUNTER INTUITIVELY BECAUSE THE
BORROWERS WILL NOT TAKE ON AS
MUCH OF THAT IN A SHARED
APPRECIATION PROGRAM GOD THEY
PAY OFF THAT DEBT MORE SLOWLY
AND IT TAKES A LITTLE BIT LONGER
UNDER THIS TYPE OF A PROGRAM.
FOR THEM TO REACH THE 80% LOAN
TO VALUE ACCESS AND IT DOESN'T
OR SOME OTHER PROGRAM SO WANT TO
BE CLEAR IT REALLY TAKES A
MOSAIC OF SOLUTIONS IN ORDER TO.
ADDRESS ALL THE NEEDS OF THE
HOMEOWNERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS IS ONE BIG TILE
IN THE MOSAIC BUT THESE OTHER
PROGRAMS REMAIN VITAL. SO LET ME
JUST DON KING WITH THAT CALL OF
SCENARIOS BECAUSE I REALLY WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THE DOWNSIDE
PROTECTION- THAT EXISTS. IN FIVE
IN THESE PROGRAMS. AND JUST SO
YOU KNOW IF YOU ARE LOOKING AT
PURCHASING. WITH A SINGLE FAMILY
HOME- THE HOME BUYERS A SMALL
DOWN PAYMENT THEY CAN GET THAT
FROM OTHER PROGRAMS THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM PROGRAM PUTS IN
A CHUNK OF THAT TIME AND THEN
TIE ON TOP OF THE FIRST
MORTGAGE. ONE OF THE THINGS I
THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
CALL OUT HOW WE DESIGNED THIS
PROGRAM. IN THE DOWNSIDE
SCENARIO A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS SORT OF
THING BECAUSE THEY REMEMBER THE
GREAT RECESSION DAY REMEMBER HOW
PEOPLE ENDED UP UNDERWATER THE
WINNING DESIGN THIS PROGRAM THE
PROGRAM ITSELF TAKES MORE OF THE
HIT. IN A DEPRECIATION SCENARIO
AND THE HOMEOWNER EVEN UNDER
DEPRECIATION OVER TIME ENDS UP
BUILDING THEIR EQUITY IN THE
PROGRAM SO THAT IN ALL RIGHT
SCENARIO THAT'S NOT OBVIOUSLY
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR BUT WE
NEED TO DESIGN FOR IT. THE OTHER
SCENARIO IS WHAT WE CALL THE
EXPECTED SCENARIO IT ENVISIONS
ACTUALLY A SLIGHTLY LOWER LEVEL
OF HOME PRICE APPRECIATION THAN
WE'VE SEEN IN CALIFORNIA TO BE
CONSERVATIVE. BUT IN THAT
SCENARIO OBVIOUSLY- AND THAT
HOME BUYERS EQUITY GOES UP
SUBSTANTIALLY THE PROGRAM- IT
MAKES MONEY AND- AND THEN THE
FIRST MORTGAGE GET PAID OFF. AND
I JUST WANT TO SAY AGAIN THE
STATE DOES NOT MAKE MONEY ON
THIS PROGRAM THIS IS THAT MONEY
IS PLOUGHED BACK INTO THE
PROGRAM TO HELP OTHER HOME
BUYERS WHICH WE THINK IS A
REALLY CRITICAL FEATURES HERE-
AND- THAT. PRO TEAM I'M- FOLKS
IN A JOURNEY ADVISED CSGN. THE
DESIGN SHARED APPRECIATION
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE NATION AND
INCLUDING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IN
THIS STATE. AND I JUST WANT TO
DRAW THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS. AND IN
WHAT WE'RE PRODUCING HERE WE'RE
NOT LOOKING TO PROVIDE THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM MADE THE SAME
STRONG RATE OF RETURN FOR EQUITY
INVESTORS IN THE PRIVATE MARKET
PROGRAMS ARE DOING. THEY ARE
FINE BUT WE PRODUCES
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE WEALTH FOR
THE HOMEOWNERS SUBSTANTIALLY
MORE DOWNSIDE PROTECTION THAN
SOME OF THOSE PRIVATE MARKET
OPTIONS. AND THAT'S WHY WE THINK
THAT THIS IS A REALLY GOOD
COMPLEMENT TO THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE. SO ME
JUST CONCLUDE BY SAYING HOW
APPRECIATIVE WE ARE OF PRESIDENT
PRO TEM ATKINS FOR ADVANCING
THIS PROPOSAL TO TREASURE MOCKED
FOR OVERSEEING THE PROJECT. AND
WE HAVE A TERRIFIC OPPORTUNITY
HERE TO RIGHT THE WRONGS OF THE
LAST CENTURY AND BUILD EQUITY IN
THE STATE THROUGH BUILDING
ACTUAL EQUITY FOR FAMILIES IN
OUR STATES DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU AND NOW MR WEBER YOU
MENTIONED THAT THERE ARE SOME
OTHER FOLKS- THAT MIGHT EITHER
BE ABLE TO ANSWER SOME QUESTIONS
OR MIGHT ALSO BE PRESENTING SO I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE- THAT.
RENDON CHAIR YEAH. THEY WILL BE
A PART OF THE FORMAL
PRESENTATION OKAY BUT THEY'RE
HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ON THE
ONE HAND. SIDE FOR ANY YOU KNOW
VERY TECHNICAL QUESTION OKAY
PERFECT ALL RIGHT SO NOW WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO. BACK TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR A
DISCUSSION SENATOR COVER YOUR-
DO YOU HAVE ANY. QUESTIONS
ACTUALLY I DO HAVE A QUESTION
FRIENDLY- SO I REALLY- I LIKED
THE PRESENTATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR- FOR GOING OVER IN
DETAIL HOW THE PROGRAM WOULD
WORK. I WILL TELL YOU THAT THE
PART THAT I LIKE THE MOST WELL
THERE'S TWO PIECES ONE IS THAT.
THE TRADITIONAL MODELS ARE A
GRANT. GRANT PROGRAM AND SO IT'S
FINITE ONCE YOU MEET HIM WHEN TO
USE THE GRANT FUNDS FOR DOWN.
PAYMENT ASSISTANCE- IT BEAT A
YOU HAVE TO KEEP UP WITH FINDING
IT IN ORDER FOR THAT PROGRAM TO
CONTINUE- WE DID THIS IN IN OUR
CITY FOR- A NUMBER OF YEARS AND
AT THAT TIME. A TEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR GRANT WOULD GET YOU INTO-
YOUR FIRST HOME- BY THE END OF
THE PROGRAM BECAUSE OF THE-
PRESSURE FROM SILICON VALLEY- WE
HAD TO INCREASE THE GRANTS TO
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS BUT ONCE
YOU. ONCE YOU USED UP YOUR PART
OF MONEY THERE WAS IN THERE IT
WAS GONE. AND AND THE HOMEOWNERS
BENEFITTED I'M THOSE FAMILIES-
IT WAS IT WAS IT FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGE THEIR LIVES BUT BUT
THERE'S A FINITE NUMBER THATYOU
CAN HELP IN THAT INSTANCE- THE
OTHER MODEL IS ONE THAT SAYS-
THAT. XBT YOU DON'T GET TO KEEP
HOME AND- THAT'S GOT ALL KINDS
OF PROBLEMS THE PRINCIPLE ONE IS
THAT. IT'S NOT REALLY YOUR HOME
YOU'RE JUST RENTING IT DURING
THE PERIOD OF TIME YOU'RE LIVING
IN IT AND SHOULD YOU NEED A
LARGER PAIR YOU CAN'T USE THE
EQUITY IN THE HOME IN ORDER TO
MAKE THAT LARGER PAIR. AND WE
SEEN THAT IMPOSED ON
FARMWORKERS- ALL OVER THE PLACE
AND IT'S FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR-
BUT IT KEEPS THE PROPERTY
AFFORDABLE- IN PERPETUITY WHICH
IS WHAT SOME GROUPS REALLY LIKE-
AND I PERSONALLY THINK IS- IS
DISCRIMINATORY QUITE FRANKLY IF
I'M GONNA PAY A MORTGAGE I WANT
TO KNOW THAT I'M GOING TO.
BENEFIT FROM THE- FROM THE
EQUITY. IN A MINUTE TAKE REAL
GOOD CARE OF IT SO THAT THAT
EQUITY IS UP AS HIGH AS POSSIBLE
SO THIS THIS REALLY- PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE FUND TO
CONTINUE TO EXIST AND FOR THE
HOMEOWNER TO BE ABLE TO SHARE.
TO SHARE AND BENEFIT FROM THE
EQUITY AND I THINK THAT THIS IS
JUST BRILLIANT SO THE QUESTION
THAT I HAVE IN IN TERMS OF A
LONG TERM STRATEGY IS- WERE YOU
ABLE TO CALCULATE- ASSUMING SOME
SOME RISKS. IN THIS KIND OF A OF
A PROGRAM- HOW LONG OR- HOW. HOW
FAR OUT THAT THE MONEY IS LIKELY
TO. CONTINUE TO BE UTILIZED MAN
I KNOW THAT'S A DIFFICULT
QUESTION BECAUSE YOU GOT TO LOOK
AT THE CRYSTAL BALL AND IT'S
HARD TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA
BUT- IF I THINK THERE'S SOME
PROJECTIONS ARE PROBABLY. BE ME
. OUR THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER.
YEAH IT IS IN FACT A DIFFICULT
AND THEREFORE I WILL HAVE IT
OVER TO MAKE IT. PETER WHO HAS
THE SOME OF THE LONG TERM
PROJECTIONS OF THAT- HI ABILITY
TO USE THE FUNDS ACTUALLY OUT TO
SIXTY YEARS I BELIEVE. MY COULD
YOU WATER- SHOWS WHY ELEVEN. I
THINK IT MIGHT BE USEFUL AND
ALSO IF YOU COULD IN THAT- IF
YOU COULD. LET US KNOW WHAT THE
OVERHEAD. IN TERMS OF THE
MANAGEMENT OF THE OF THE FUND
WOULD BE SURE. I WILL DO THAT.
CAN MAKE IT BIGGER OKAY. BURKE
CHAU EIGHT HERE'S WHAT WE DID IN
MOSCOW CRUISING ON A SHARED
APPRECIATION WE'VE ALSO DONE AN
ANALYSIS SINCE SIX SIMPLE
INTEREST BUILDINGS FOCUSED ON
THE SHARED APPRECIATION PROBABLY
GETTING NEED TO READ IT TO US
BECAUSE I YES. OKAY THREE TV'S
THAT WE HAVE IN FRONT OF US ARE
ARE THE SMALLER ONES ARE YES AND
HIGH UP OKAY. OKAY FINE SO THE
FUNDS WILL MEET FIRSTHAND FOR
THE QUESTION ABOUT THE COST OF
THE PROGRAM SO. THIS WAS
DESIGNED AND MODELED IN THE TOWN
OF SPENCER MODELING FROM LAST
TWO MONTHS. COM FOUR INVESTMENT
OF A BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR FROM
THE STATE FOR TEN YEARS THINGS
FIXED AMOUNTS FROM. TO MAKE
LOANS TO MAKE THE ACTUAL SECOND
MORTGAGE LOANS THESE SHARED
APPRECIATION MONTHS. WE'VE ALSO
BUDGETED. FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR. FOR MINISTRY OF
COST. ON BEYOND YOU KNOW YEAR
AFTER YEAR THE ON YOUR TENT BUT
STILL THE SAME HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR LEVEL TO MAKE CERTAIN
THAT WAS ADEQUATE. FOR THE HOME
PURCHASE COUNSELING AND
SERVICING AND OTHER COSTS SO
WE'VE BUILT THAT. FALL INTO INTO
THIS. IN THE- THE TOTAL TAXPAYER
FUNDING OVER THESE OVER THE MANY
YEARS WOULD BE FOURTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS INCLUDING THE
ADMINISTRATION OUT FORTY YEARS.
WHICH AT THE PRESENT VALUE OF
TEN POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS.
COST SO THAT'S WHAT THE
COSTUMES. SO NOW THE QUESTION IS
WHAT IS THE STATE'S DOING BY
CREATING THIS DEDICATED
REVOLVING INVESTMENT FUND. ARMS
WITH OUT SO. IN THE BEGINNING
YEARS THE PRO. IT SERVES.
SEVENTY SEVEN HUNDRED- BORROWERS
A YEAR A LITTLE UNDER A THOUSAND
SOCIAL DEPEND ON WHAT PRICES
PEOPLE ACTUALLY PAY. BUT THAT'S
OUR ESTIMATE. HIM SO IT'S
STARTING BY SERVING SEVENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED BORROWERS YEAR
OVER TIME IS THE REPAYMENTS COME
BACK. THIS DEPENDS ON THE
APPRECIATION RATE. ARMS WERE
ABLE THEN TO TAKE THE MONEY AND
HELP SUBSEQUENT BUYERS IN ORDER
THIS FORTY YEAR PERIOD WE'RE
HELPING A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SEVEN THOUSAND FAMILIES. ARMS SO
IT CONTINUES ON IS A RECYCLING
PROGRAM. AND THE TOTAL PRICE. OF
THE HOME PURCHASED. WITH ARMED
WITH THIS MUCH IN THE STATE'S
MONEY IS THE KEY ARM BECAUSE
OTHERWISE PEOPLE WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO BUY THESE HOME TO THIRTY
EIGHT GOING DOLLARS. WE PROVIDE
FOR SEVEN DOLLARS OF LAW FROM.
SO STARTING WITH THE SAME
BILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE WE'RE
RECYCLING IN APPRECIATION. AND
WE NOW LOOK THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION WHICH WAS
WHAT IS THE BORROWER SURE OF THE
HOME PLEASE SHE H. BECAUSE AFTER
ALL. THEY ARE PAYING SOMETHING
TO US IF WE PUT UP 17% OF THE
PURCHASE PRICE THE STATE PUTS
UP. THE STATE GETS 17%
APPRECIATION OF OUR OR GETS 83%
OF THE APPRECIATION. SO WHAT
HAPPENS OVERALL TO THE TOTAL
APPRECIATION ARE WE TAKING SO
MUCH FROM THE BORROWER THEY WERE
LIMITING THE TOTAL HOUSEHOLD
WEALTH IS CREATED. NO WE FOUND
WAS THAT OVER TIME WE'RE
CREATING A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS OF
HOUSEHOLD WEALTH FOR BORROWERS
IN STATE. AND THE PORTIONS THAT
IS FOR YOU CORRECT AT THE END OF
THAT FOUR YEAR PERIOD THE STATE
HAS MONEY TO STILL DO IT WHEN
THOSE BORROWERS WHO ARE STILL
OUTSTANDING G. MAKING LOANS ON
THE STATE GETS BACK THIRTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS OVER TIME
THAT'LL HELP FUTURE BORROWERS SO
WE FOUND. THAT THE NET COST FROM
THE STATE FOR INVESTING WITH
BORROWERS IS ROUGHLY CREATING
TWENTY IS ROUGHLY CREAM TWENTY
TIMES THE AMOUNT OF HOUSEHOLD
WEALTH WITH THE STATE ITSELF IS
INVESTING WITH ITS OWN FUNDS
SHOWS THE VERY EFFICIENT PROGRAM
FOR HELPING BUILD HOUSEHOLD
WEALTH FOR LOTS OF BORUSAN.
STATE IN THE KEY THING. MAYBE
THE MOST THINGS THAT SHE TO
CREATE. NOBODY KNOWS WHAT THE
RATE OF BEING IS GONNA BE. IN
ANY YEAR AS- EVERYBODY SISTAN
TRUMP LAST YEAR'S WITH PRICES
GOING UP 40% BECAUSE OF
APPRECIATE. IS CAN MATCH THAT.
SO THE- IF PRICES CONTINUE TO
RISE FROM. THE STATE GETS MORE
MONEY TO HELP SUBSEQUENT BUYERS
OTHERWISE YOU HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE YOU'RE JUST GETTING BACK
THE MONEY YOU LANCE FOR SOME
SIMPLE INTEREST RATES. IF PRICES
HAVE RISEN YOU DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY TO HELP THE NEXT FIRE SO
THE WHOLE PURPOSES THIS IS OUR
PRICES GO UP A LOT YOU CAN
CONTINUE HELPING BUYERS WITHOUT
A ROADING. THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
YOU CAN HELP. AT THE SAME TIME
IF PRICES ARE FLASHED BORACAY'S
KNOWS THREE SHE H. SO THERE'S N
OBLIGATION. TO PAY ANYTHING-
OTHER THAN THE ORIGINAL
PRINCIPLES SO WHICH INTENDED TO.
WORKS WHETHER REACHED WHETHER
POLLUTION IS HIGH OR IS LOWER IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE TO
SERVE BORROWERS IN A FAIR WAY.
THAT'S MY SUMMARY THE MODEL
THANKS GENE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT SOME AN EXCELLENT. AND I
REALLY LIKE THIS PROGRAM I THINK
IT IT- IT CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR PEACE FOR PEOPLE TO. BUILD
BUILD EQUITY IN WEALTH BUT JUST
AS IMPORTANT IS THE ABILITY TO
STABILIZE YOUR FAMILY AND- AND
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT THE
STATE DOES IS- IN IN- IN SOME
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE VERY FEW OF
THE PEOPLE ACTUALLY ON THE HOME
THE HOMES- THIS HELPS TO
STABILIZE COMMUNITY STABILIZE
FAMILIES AND SO I REALLY
APPRECIATED IN THE THANK YOU SO
MUCH I DON'T HAVE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS THIS IS JUST REALLY
IMPRESSIVE. THANK YOU SENATOR
KABIR ALSO I. ALSO THINK THAT
THIS IS. THE RIGHT TRACK- FOR
HOW WE WORK TO ADDRESS
HOMEOWNERSHIP IN THE ENTRY INTO
THEM. THE 17% SEEMS TO BE STATIC
YES. I'M IN THE CENTER OF IT
SEVENTY BURKE 17% DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE. YES OKAY SO MY SORT
OF- I'M THINKING ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM IN RELATIONSHIP TO MY
DISTRICT WHICH IS INCREDIBLY
DIVERSE- AND ALSO IS A DISTRICT
THAT IS BEING CHALLENGED BY
XCELERATED GENTRIFICATION. AND
SO ANY THOUGHTS ON. HOW WE ALLOW
OR ENSURE THAT HOMEOWNERS ARE
ABLE TO. COMPETE FOR HOMES IN
THE COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY WANT
TO LIVE- I WOULD NOT WANT IN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE TO BE
THAT FOLKS ARE PUSHED INTO
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES WHERE THE
MEDIAN PRICE- YOU KNOW IS A
NUMBER THAT PEOPLE FEEL
COMFORTABLE. HAVING CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES PURCHASE RIGHT AND
SO WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT FOR
AYE YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN YEAH
ABSOLUTELY LET ME LET ME SAY TWO
THINGS CORRECTLY FIRST- ACTUALLY
WE'RE DESIGNING I CAN'T YOUR
QUESTION CORRECTLY THE SECOND
TIME WE'RE DESIGNING IT SUCH
THAT YOU CAN. THE PROGRAM WITH A
LARGER PERCENTAGE OF DOWN
PAYMENT ASSISTANCE SHOULD YOU
CHOOSE- WE RECOMMEND NO MORE
THAN THIRTY PERCENT- THE NUMBERS
HERE- WE'RE PROPOSING ARE 17%
AND I THINK ANOTHER KEY ISSUE
HERE IS THAT- YOU KNOW SAY
LEGISLATORS GOING TO HAVE TO
DECIDE THE LEVEL OF DETAIL THAT
THEY WANT TO PROVIDE. IN THE
ENABLING LEGISLATION OBVIOUSLY
THE ADMINISTRATING AGENCIES ARE
YOU KNOW GOING TO MAKE. VARIOUS
DECISIONS IN THAT REGARD. BUT
PERHAPS I COULD TURN IT OVER
QUICKLY TO IT TO KATE COLLINS TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT. ABOUT. THE
RESPONSE TO YOUR QUESTION. AND
THANK YOU. SO I IN RESPONSE THE
DESCENDING WE'VE DEBATED DEEPLY-
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO
RESTRICT PEOPLE EITHER TO BEING
IN THE PLACE. THAT YOU KNOW THEY
DON'T WANT WE DON'T WANT TO TELL
PEOPLE WHERE THEY CAN BUY A HOME
SO THE REASON WE SET THINGS THE
WAY WE HAVE AS WE TRY TO.
ACCOMMODATE FOR A HIGH ENOUGH-
SHARE THAT PEOPLE COME BY IN
THEIR COMMUNITY THEY COULD
CHOOSE TO GO SOMEWHERE ELSE-
THAT WAS INTENTIONAL WE LOOK
REALLY CAREFULLY AT THAT.
THERE'S A HUGE VARIANCE IN BOTH
HOUSEHOLD INCOME AS WELL AS
MEDIAN HOUSE PRICE ACROSS THE
STATE AND WE WANTED TO SAY EVERY
YOU'LL SEE AS MANY TRADITIONAL
DOWN PAYMENT ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
WILL OFFER. A NUMBER LIKE A
LIMIT FOR THE INCOME AND A LIMIT
FOR THE AMOUNT OF ASSISTANCE AND
HERE WE'RE THINKING ABOUT IT AS
A SHARE IN ORDER TO ACCOMMODATE
FOR JUST BACK. WE ALSO WANT TO
NOTE THAT. AS YOU KNOW IT TO
MICHAEL'S POINT AS THE
ADMINISTRATOR THINKS THROUGH HOW
THAT HOW THIS PROGRAM IS
DISTRIBUTED THE FUNDS ARE
DISTRIBUTED. I HAVEN'T WE DO
BELIEVE THERE WILL BE
RESERVATIONS FOR DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES AND I THINK THAT THE
STATE HAS A LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES
TO THINK ABOUT. HOW BEST TO
SERVE AND I CAN BE THERE CAN BE
IT CAN PLACE BASED ELEMENT TO
THAT THAT WE THINK- WELL WE'LL
TRY TO HELP WITH THAT WITH
JUSTICE YOU BRING UPGRADE. THANK
YOU AND WITH YOU WHEN YOU SAY
I'M SORRY WHEN YOU SAY
RESERVATIONS DO YOU MEAN
RESERVATIONS LIKE I'M MAKING A
RESERVATION AT THE RESTAURANT
READY ME RESERVATIONS LIKE
HESITANCY. NO I'M SORRY. YOU'RE
TAKING A POOR I KNOW THAT'S A
BIT. PROBABLY BETTER. AS MANY
MEETINGS I'M I TAKE A POOR AND
RESERVE OKAY FUNDS FOR THIS
GROUPS AND SO WORK I MEAN THAT
THERE'S AN ABILITY TO TARGET TO
THE GROUPS THAT THAT YOU WANT TO
OVERTIME THERE HOW YOU
DISTRIBUTE THE FUNDS. ADULT
ACCOMMODATE ANY DISPLACEMENT
SHALL BE ABLE TO. MADAM CHAIR DO
YOU MIND IF I HAVE ON A PRE
OWNED THIS CRITICALLY ADDRESS
THIS QUESTION AS WELL HI THEY'VE
DONE A LOT OF. OUTREACH IN THE
SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND GOT SOME GREAT
DIRECT FEEDBACK THAT I THINK IS
RELEVANT. I DON'T MIND. OKAY
GOOD. GALA GREAT THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR- AS
MICHAEL MENTIONED WE WE'VE
SPOKEN THROUGH CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY BUILDERS WE SPOKEN
WITH ABOUT FIFTEEN ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE PRIMARILY
HOUSING COUNSELORS. I SEE A VICE
MORTGAGE ORIGINATORS AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE HEARD
CONSISTENTLY WAS THIS IS A GREAT
PROGRAM THIS ADDS A GREAT NEW
TOOL TO THE TOOLBOX IN
CALIFORNIA FOR CREATING FIRST
TIME HOME BUYERS- BUT ONE THING
THAT FOLKS CONSISTENTLY GOT BACK
TO US WITH WAS. THIS IS A FAIRLY
COMPLEX PROGRAM AND IN AREAS
SUCH AS LOS ANGELES IN THE BAY
AREA WHERE FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS ARE REALLY STRUGGLE THERE
NEEDS TO REALLY BE AS AS MANY
RESOURCES IN SUPPORT AS POSSIBLE
FOR HOUSING COUNSELORS. TO
EDUCATE FAMILIES ARE THAT
PERHAPS DON'T THINK THEY CAN
AFFORD HOMEOWNERSHIP THAT
PERHAPS HAVE TRIED. EXISTING
FIRST TIME HOME BUYER PROBLEMS-
I PROGRAMS AND ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS THEM ALSO REALLY ENSURING
THAT WE MAXIMIZE SUPPORT AND
RESOURCES FOR COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AND HOUSING
COUNSELORS- WE THINK WILL BE A
GREAT ANTIDOTE. TO BOTH SOME OF
THE INHERENT COMPLEXITY THAT'S
PROGRAM AND ALSO ENSURING THAT
THAT FAMILIES REALIZE THEY DON'T
HAVE TO LEAVE THEIR COMMUNITIES
THEY CAN STAY WHERE THEY WANT TO
WE'VE BUILT AS MUCH FLEXIBILITY
AS WE THINK REASONABLE
IMPOSSIBLE IN THIS PROGRAM. SO
THAT FOLKS CAN STAY WHERE THEY
ARE OUR GENTRIFIED OUT AREN'T
JUST PLACED OUT AND WE THINK THE
KEY TO THAT IS REALLY RESOURCING
AND SUPPORTING COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AND HOUSING
COUNSELORS. I SUPPORT THOSE
FAMILIES. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THAT- SO I DO THANK YOU FOR
SHARING BECAUSE I ALSO THINK
THAT EDUCATION IS KEY NOT JUST
ABOUT LETTING FOLKS KNOW THAT
THIS IS A POTENTIAL PROGRAM THAT
WILL EXIST BUT ALSO EDUCATING
FOLKS ABOUT THE PRICE
DIFFERENTIALS THAT ARE VERY REAL
ACROSS THE STATE- RELATED TO.
HOW EXPENSIVE HOMES CAN BE IN
CERTAIN PARTS OF THE STATE- AND
SO I WOULD JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT- YOU KNOW LIKE THERE
AREN'T PRICE THRESHOLDS BECAUSE
I COULD CONCEIVABLY HERE PEOPLE
SAY WOLVES MAYBE YOU SHOULDN'T
HAVE TO PURCHASE A LIKE I DON'T
WANT THIS TO GO TO A HOME THAT
COSTS ZERO ONE MILLION DOLLARS
WHY DO YOU NEED A ONE MILLION
DOLLAR HOUSE. WHEN THE REALITY
IS MAYBE IN CERTAIN COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE STILL WORKING CLASS-
THAT'S JUST HOW MUCH IT COSTS
YOU KNOW BECAUSE OF THE MARKET-
OR YOU DON'T WANT A SITUATION
WHERE YOU KNOW CERTAIN ZIP CODES
ARE EXCLUDED- BECAUSE FOLKS
SHOULDN'T NECESSARILY BE TRYING
TO LIVE. IN COMMUNITY A THEY
SHOULD STAY IN COMMUNITY B. AND
I KNOW THIS IS ABOUT FIRST TIME
HOMEOWNERSHIP BUT THERE COULD
ALSO BE INSTANCES WHERE. THERE
IS A HOME THAT IS OWNED BY. A
FAMILY MEMBER THAT THEY WOULD
LIKE TO THEN SELL TO A NOTHER
FAMILY MEMBER BECAUSE THEY WANT
TO KEEP IT IN THE FAMILY OR SOME
SORT OF YOU KNOW THERE MIGHT BE
YOU KNOW TRANSFER WITH PURCHASES
ETCETERA. AND IF THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR THOSE TYPES
OF- PURCHASES TO BE. CONSIDERED
BECAUSE MAYBE A FAMILY IS REALLY
INTERESTED IN KEEPING THAT HOUSE
YOU KNOW. EIGHT IN THEIR NAME
BUT FOLKS ARE TRYING TO
NECESSARILY GIVE THE HOUSE AWAY
SO- DOES THAT DOES THAT MAKE
SENSE THAT UNDERSTANDS- AND WE
ACTUALLY RECOMMEND DESIGNING THE
PROGRAM WITH MORE FLEXIBILITY-
DIED SAID TO ADDRESS SITUATIONS
LIKE SUCH AS THAT I ALSO WANT TO
AGAIN REALLY THANK. ESPECIALLY
THE TEEMING CAL HFA FRIENDS
ASKING HOW THE OTHER FOLKS OVER
THERE FOR PROVIDING SOME
TREMENDOUS TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO HELP US UNDERSTAND BETTER HOW
THEIR EXISTING YOU KNOW DELIVERY
AND COUNCIL THAT WORKS CAN BE
TAPPED TO ACHIEVE THE EXACT AND
SAT OUTSIDE THE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT YEAH YEAH AND THE OTHER
THING AND THIS WILL JUST BE MY
FINAL IS THAT. YOU KNOW. I WOULD
HATE FOR US TO GET INTO A
SCENARIO WHERE WE SAY X. NUMBER
OF HOMES YOU KNOW IN NORTHERN
CAL X. NUMBER OF HOMES IN
SOUTHERN CAL X. NUMBER OF HOMES
IN CENTRAL VALLEY X. NUMBER OF
HOMES IN SAN DIEGO BECAUSE ONCE
AGAIN. A LOT OF THIS IS
PREDICATED ON THE MARKET. AND
YOU CAN'T YOU KNOW EQUOL. IS
DIFFERENCE BASED ON JUST WHAT
THINGS COST AND SO YOU IF YOU
DID IT THAT WAY SO THAT EVERYONE
GOT YOU KNOW THE SAME AMOUNTS
RIGHT OF MONEY OF ACCESS. THEN
SOME COMMUNITIES WOULD BE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
BECAUSE LESS WOULD GO TO THEM
JUST BECAUSE THE COST. ARE ARE
ARE MUCH HIGHER AND I'M THINKING
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT LATE AND OF
COURSE THE BAY AREA AND I KNOW
THOSE TWO REGIONS GET YOU KNOW
CALLED OUT QUITE A BIT BUT THEY
JUST ARE REALLY EXPENSIVE.
THAT'S IT FOR ME IS THAT IT FOR
YOU MIKE UP YES THANK YOU SO
MUCH ALL RIGHT SO THIS IS A HOLD
OPEN ITEM AND WE ARE GOING TO
AND DIRECTS STAFF TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ON AT REDEFINING
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM FOR ALSO
THAT WE CAN ALL HAVE A
CALIFORNIA DREAM- SO NOW WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER- ELEVEN WHICH IS A
DIVISION OF STATE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE BUDGET ADJUSTMENTS.
AND H. C. D. I THINK NOW THIS IS
YOU ARE YOU READY TO PRESENT. I
AM YOU MADAM CHAIR- THANK YOU MY
pNAME IS ZACH OLMSTEAD I'M THE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. I BELIEVE
YOU WANT ME TO GO ISSUE TEN
FIRST PARTITIONOF STATE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE BUDGET YEAH
MY NUMBRS ARE ALL SQUARELY. ALL
THAT BUT THANK YOU FOR MAKING
SURE I GIVE YOU A- ISSUE NUMBER
TEN. THANK YOU- SO ON THIS ITEM
EACH THE REQUEST A BUDGETARY
AUTHORITY ADJUSTMENT TO THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM.
TO ENSURE UNSPENT FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE TO HELP MEET THE STATE
SCHOOLS ON BUILDING AFFORDABLE
SUSTAINABLE HOUSING. THERE'S AN
UNCOMMITTED BALANCE OF ABOUT
SIXTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION OF
THE TWENTY FOURTEEN FOR HOUSING
AND SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
CORPORATION THAT TO DO TO CANCEL
PROJECTS AND SAVINGS WE DIDN'T
ABLE TO REALIZE THE SUPPORTS
BUDGET. SO IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THE CONTINUED AVAILABILITY OF
THESE FUNDS FOR HOUSING THEIR
INTENDED PURPOSE WE'RE
REQUESTING. EXTENSION OF THE
INCOME RANGE. IN ORDER TO A WAR
THOSE FUN IN YOUR- WITH THAT
RICK THIS REAPPROPRIATION ABOUT
SIXTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION WOULD
BE LOST FOR HOUSING PURPOSES.
AND REVERT BACK TO THE JUDGE- TO
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND. SO WE WOULDN'T PLAN TO
MAKE THESE AWARDS AS PART OF OUR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO FUNDING ROUNDS
UNDER THAT CONTINUES
CORPORATION- AN ADDITIONAL SIX
MILLION REPRESENTS THE REMAINING
DISBURSEMENTS AND CURRENT. TO
CURRENT IN PROGRESS PROJECTS
RUNNING UP AGAINST THAT THE
SCENE COMMERCE DEADLINE SO AS
NOTED IN THE AGENDA
REVERBERATING A TOTAL OF TWENTY
TWO MILLION FROM THE TWENTY
FOURTEEN PROCREATION WILL ALLOW
YOU TO COMPLETE THE WORK FOR
WHICH THE FUNDS WERE ORIGINALLY
ENCUMBERED. EXTENDING THAT
INCOME RISKY. FROM SIX THIRTY
TWENTY TWO TO SIX THIRTY TWENTY
FOUR WILL ALLOW FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING GRANTEES TO COMPLETE THE
PROJECTS THAT ARE ALREADY
CURRENTLY PROGRESS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- THE FINANCE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PROVIDE ANY COMMENT. AND
YOUR MARCH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- WHERE DOES ADD THAT-
THE CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION
REQUEST IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
ADDITIONAL OR THAT CURRENT-
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES FUNDING HAS PROVIDED
FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND SO THIS IS A- IN
ORDER TO ALIGN THE PROGRAM WITH
PREVIOUSLY APPROPRIATED FUNDS.
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU L. A. O.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROVIDE ANY
COMMENT. WHEN I WAS THE ONLY- WE
HAVE NO ISSUES TRICKS ON THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU ARE GOING TO NOW BRING IT
BACK TO OPEN DISCUSSION WITH
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SENATOR
COPIER- DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. NO I
DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU I
JUST HAVE ONE HAVE WE'VE
IDENTIFIED THE WHERE THESE FOUR.
ARE LOCATED THE FOUR PROJECTS.
THE PROJECT. THE PRODUCT NAMES
ARE IN YOUR AGENDA- I COULD LOOK
UP REAL QUICK I DON'T HAVE THEM
MEMORIZED FOR ALL OF OUR
PORTFOLIO WITH THIS PROJECT
LOCATED. OKAY I CAN CERTAINLY-
LET MY COLLEAGUES HERE AND
HOPEFULLY MAYBE SHE'D EVER SEE
HER SHE COULD IDENTIFY THAT
BECAUSE- CRIED THAT TO YOU
WITHIN. A COUPLE MINUTES. OKAY
GREAT WELL THIS IS APPROVED AS
BUDGET IN. I WILL SAY THAT THAT
WILL NOT STOP IT FROM MOVING BUT
I WAS CURIOUS OKAY SO WE'RE DONE
WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA NOW MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT ITEM- ISSUE
NUMBER ELEVEN THE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT
MITIGATION PROGRAM. AT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT. AGAIN THANK YOU
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE EACH
DAY IS REQUESTING A LITTLE OVER
FIFTY SIX MILLION IN THE FEDERAL
TRUST FUND AND FOR POSITIONS. IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. AS WELL
AS- EIGHT THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND.
EIGHT TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
IT'S AN ONGOING RESOURCES TO
MANAGE AND OVERSEE THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE COMMUNITY
BUILDING BLOCK GRANT. MITIGATION
PROGRAMS SOME HELPFUL- THIS IS A
PROGRAM TO FUND MITIGATION
EFFORTS TO PREVENT FURTHER
IMPACT FROM DISASTER WILL
PREVENT FUTURE DISASTERS FROM
OCCURRING. IN THAT AREA AND THIS
FEDERAL FUNDING WAS ALLOCATED TO
CALIFORNIA TO INCREASE
RESILIENCE TO DISASTERS. AND
REDUCE OR ELIMINATE THE LONG
TERM RISK OF LOSS OF LIFE
INJURY. DAMAGE TO AND LOSS OF
PROPERTY AND SUFFERING AND
HARDSHIP THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN. WILDFIRES
THIS IS A BRAND NEW PROGRAM FOR
BOTH TIED IN FOR CALIFORNIA. IN
THIS REQUEST WILL ALLOW. YOU TO
FULLY IMPLEMENT THE FUNDING THAT
HAS RECENTLY BEEN RECONFIGURED.
TO BETTER SYSTEMS DISASTER
AFFECTED JURISDICTIONS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FINANCE. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PROVIDE ANY COMMENT. THE
END OF MARCH FROM THE FINANCE-
NO. COME L. A- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PER ANY. MOTIONS DRIZZLE RIPPLES
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND ARE
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SENATOR
KABIR ANY OF ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS YES I DO HAVE
QUESTIONS- SO- IS THIS
PARTICULAR ITEM. BASICALLY LISTS
FIFTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WE'RE GETTING FROM THE- FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BUT THE ONLY THING
THAT ARE LISTED ARE. EXPENSES
RELATED TO DISTRIBUTING THE
MONEY NOT. ANY DETAIL ABOUT WHAT
THE MONEY'S GOING TO BE USED FOR
CAN SOMEBODY GIVE ME AN IDEA
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT- HOW WE
INTEND TO. TO YOU KNOW WHAT KIND
OF GRANTS AND HOW DO THEY GET
DISTRIBUTED- WHAT'S- WHAT'S OUR
PRIORITY FOR SPENDING WHAT IS.
REALLY INCREDIBLE- RESOURCES TO-
BE ABLE TO MEET THE- DISASTER
NEEDS IN OUR STATE AND YOU KNOW
EVERY REGION IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT- SOME HAVE. THAT THE
NATURAL DISASTERS ARE FIRES AND
OTHERS ARE FLOODING AND OTHERS
ARE- ARE POTENTIAL EARTHQUAKE SO
AS WE START LOOKING AT HOW WE
EXPAND THESE FINE TOWER HOW ARE
WE GOING TO DO IT. YEAH GREAT
QUESTIONS IS A BRAND NEW PROGRAM
LOVABLE FOR US LIKE I SAID AND
HIDE- WITH ME I DO HAVE JEFFREY
ROSS WHO HEADS ARE FEDERAL
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE DIVISION
AND HE'S BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH A LOT OF OUR DISASTER
AFFECTED COMMUNITIES SO HE CAN
PROVIDE YOU SOME SPECIFICS.
THANK MORNING- JEFF ROSS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR DIVISION OF FEDERAL
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
BECAUSE- WE'RE VERY EXCITED AS
AS THE- SHOOTER VIDEO SAID.
MENTIONED THIS IS A NEW PROGRAM
FOR HIGH END FOR US. AND SO WHAT
WE'RE GONNA BE DOING IS WORKING
WITH ARE SEVENTEEN AND EIGHTEEN
DISASTER COMMUNITIES THE PRIMARY
COMMUNITIES I THINK THAT COME TO
FOLKS MIND- FOR THOSE TWO YEARS.
ARSENAL COUNTY IN SANTA ROSA.
BUTTE COUNTY IN PARADISE THAT
THOSE ARE THE MOST IMPACTED BUT
AS WE NOW. DISASTERS CONTINUE TO
IMPACT VARIOUS COMMUNITIES.
AROUND THE STATE AS A WHOLE. AND
SO WHAT WE'RE REALLY GOING TO BE
TRYING TO DO IS WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THOSE COMMUNITIES
TO UNDERSTAND. WHAT ARE THE GAPS
IN THE CURRENT LONG TERM
RECOVERY AND MITIGATION- YOU
KNOW ENVIRONMENT THAT THAT
REALLY NEED TO BE ADDRESSED. HOW
DO WE LEVERAGE OTHER RESOURCES
IN USE THESE BONDS. AT FOR THEIR
HIGHEST AND BEST USE. IS IT'S
GOING TO BE THOSE TYPES OF
CONVERSATIONS THAT WILL BE ON
GOING IN THE MONTHS TO COME THE
REALLY ALLOW US TO IDENTIFY THAT
THE HIGHEST AND BEST USE FOR
THESE DOLLARS. BECAUSE THIS IS A
NEW ALLOCATION- WE DO ALSO
ANTICIPATE THAT AS ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FLOW FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THIS ACTIVITY WILL
WILL ALSO NOW BECOME PART OF THE
LARGER DISASTER RECOVERY
RESPONSE EFFORTS. AND SO WE
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE THINKING OF
MITIGATION ON SEVERAL LEVELS OF
PLANNING. AND SUSTAINABILITY.
INFRASTRUCTURE MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING AND SINGLE FAMILY
HOUSING AND CHINESE MITIGATION
ACTIVITIES VERY SPECIFICALLY. TO
THOSE OTHER EFFORTS AND THEN
AGAIN TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN- FIGURE OUT HOW THAT THE
BEST WAY TO LEVERAGE. OTHER
RESOURCES SO THAT WAY WE CAN
MAKE SURE THAT WE MAXIMIZE-
THESE THESE DOLLARS AS THEY
CONTINUE TO FLOW TOWARD
COMMUNITIES. SO IF I UNDERSTAND
YOU CORRECTLY- THIS IS THIS IS-
MITIGATION FOR PASSED-
DISASTERS. NUMBER ONE. AND
NUMBER TWO I GUESS- THE QUESTION
I HAVE BEEN AND MAY BE. WELL
ACTUALLY THE QUESTION SHOULD BE-
ARE WE GONNA SEE UP A PLAN OR
OR- A PROPOSAL AT SOME POINT SO
WE UNDERSTAND HOW THE RESOURCES
WOULD GO OUT OR ARE WE JUST
SAYING. DO WHATEVER DO WHATEVER
I GUESS IS THE QUESTION THE
REASON I SAY THAT IS BECAUSE-
THOSE FIRES TOOK OUT. HUGE
SYSTEMS WATER SYSTEMS ROADWAYS-
SO I'M I'M WONDERING IF IT'S IF
IT'S A REPLACEMENT ASSISTANCE
BUT ALSO- D. THE ABILITY TO DO A
PROACTIVE- I KIND OF HARDENING
YES BECAUSE I MEAN THE LAST
THING WE WANT IS FOR A ROOF
REPEAT IN THOSE SAME AREAS AND-
SO UGH ARE WE GONNA SEE
SOMETHING DOWN THE ROAD
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT SENATOR IT IS
NOT SIMPLE REPLACEMENT REALLY IS
TRYING TO MAKE SURE AS WE BUILD
BACK WE ARE BUILDING BACK. WE
ARE HARD MEAN WE ARE BEING MORE
RESILIENT WE ARE MINDFUL OF THE-
THE DANGERS THAT EXIST AND SO
THAT WAY COMMUNITIES CAN
FUNCTION WE DO AS A AS A PART OF
THESE FINES HAVE TO GO THROUGH
WHAT IS KNOWN AS AN ACTION
PLANNING PROCESS WHERE WE ENGAGE
WITH COMMUNITIES WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THEM TO DETERMINE
AGAIN WHAT THESE THESE- BEST
USES OF MEDICATIONS ARE WE HAVE
TO SUBMIT THOSE PLANS BASED ON
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION TO THE US
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT SO THAT WAY WE CAN
THEN GO ABOUT AND UTILIZED THE
FUNDING ITSELF. SEVEN THE STAFF
IN AND THE REQUEST THAT WAS PART
OF THIS IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
IS EACH YEAR ARE PREPARED TO
WORK HAND IN HAND WITH OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND WITH HOW
IT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GO
THROUGH THAT THAT VERY MINDFUL
PLANNING PROCESS AND WE CAN VERY
CLEARLY SAY WHAT THOSE USED AS A
FUNDS WILL BE AND WE ABSOLUTELY
CAN REPORT THAT BACK ON BECAUSE
IT IS PART OF OUR ON GOING TO
FOURTEEN AND TEN EFFORTS THAT WE
DO BOTH ON HERE WITH THE STATE
AND WITH OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS.
THANK THANK YOU FOR THAT
EXPLANATION I THINK THAT WOULD
BE REALLY- WE'RE GOOD I. I'M
NOT. THAT THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
SUPPLANT WHAT LOCALS WANT DONE
IN OUR COMMUNITY BUT- TO THE
EXTENT THAT- THAT. THE RESOURCES
ARE COMING THROUGH THE STATE I
THINK IT WOULD BE GOOD TO SEE
THE REPORT IT'S GOING TO GO TO
HEAD- IF ONLY FOR INFORMATIONAL
PURPOSES I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT. WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
FEDERAL FUNDS AND- WHAT KIND OF.
OF A- IMPROVEMENTS WERE GOING TO
MAKE IN THESE IN THESE
COMMUNITIES AND BEEN SO
DEVASTATED SO I APPRECIATE THE
RESPONSE. THANK YOU SENATOR
CAREER OFFICER ON DO YOU OKAY SO
THIS IS APPROVED AS BUDGETED
THIS ITEM AND WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO OUR FINAL ITEM I'M- WITH PART
B. THE ISSUE TWELVE THE HOME
INVESTMENT PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM.
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN- ARE
YOU IN YOUR BACK AGAIN- BACK- SO
ANOTHER ANOTHER FEDERAL PROGRAM
ANOTHER NEW FEDERAL PROGRAMS- SO
EACH IS REQUESTING- NEARLY
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE MILLION-
FROM THE FEDERAL TRUST FUND
FIFTEEN POSITIONS AND THE A
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE BUDGET
YEAR ADDITIONAL RESOURCES- IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AND I'M
GOING TO PLAN DEVELOP AND
ADMINISTER THE NEW FEDERALLY
FUNDED. PROGRAM CALLED THE HOME
INVESTMENT PARTNERSHIPS AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN PROGRAM ANOTHER
MOUTHFUL- WE ALSO REQUEST
ACTUALLY LANGUAGE YOU AUTHORIZE
HE SHOULD BE TO LET THE
GUIDELINE PROCESS FOR THE WHOLE
PROGRAM AND FOR THE EMERGENCY
SOLUTIONS GRANT PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE REASON IS
THIS IS A NEW FEDERAL PROGRAM
THAT BROADLY SPEAKING COMBINED
SEVERAL ELIGIBLE USES OF FUNDS
INCLUDING YOUR FORMAL HOUSING-PRODUCTION AND PRESERVATION AND
RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND MANY OF
THESE USERS CAPS LATE WHAT IS
ALLOWABLE IN THE CURRENT NUMBERS
TO SOLUTIONS GRANT PROGRAM ALSO
ADMINISTERED BY HCD. A SUPPORT
IN THE NOTE I THINK AS THE
AGENDA DOES- THAT THIS NEW
FEDERAL PROGRAMS ALSO AN
AFFIRMATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
HOKEY PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA'S
BEEN FEATURED IN HOUSE ROLL OUT
OF THIS PROGRAM GIVEN THE L. AS
POLICE IN THAT SPACE- THE
GUIDELINE PROCESS THE COMPANY'S
REQUEST IS QUITE IMPORTANT FOR
US IN ORDER TO FOR THE STATE TO
QUICKLY DEPLOY THE FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE. OUR CURRENTLY
ENGAGES YOU'VE HEARD AND
STAKEHOLDER OUTREACH TO ALLOW
FOR PUBLIC PARTICIPATION AS
REQUIRED BY HUD THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT
PROCESS GREATLY LIMITS THE
FLEXIBILITY AND RESPONSIVENESS
OF FEDERAL PROGRAMS RESPOND TO
THAT FEDERAL GUIDANCE IN
CHANGES- THEY CAN THEY HAVE
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON NOT ONLY OUR
PERFORMANCE BUT IT COULD CREATE
ADDITIONAL RISK FREE CAPTURE
LOSS OF FEDERAL FUNDS. TO SEND
HOME A R. P. IS A HYBRID OF BOTH
THAT FEDERAL HOOK UP WITH THE
CURRENT FEDERAL HOME PROGRAM IN
THE CURRENT FEDERAL EMERGENCY
SOLUTIONS GRANT PROGRAMS AND THE
WORK IS BEING DONE FOR THIS
PROGRAM IS IN CLOSE COORDINATION
WITH THAT CURRENT ESG HOME
PROGRAMS WITH THOSE CONTINUES OF
CARE AT THE LOCAL LEVELS THAT MR
THEM- WE ASK FOR THAT KIND THAT
THAT SORT OF FLEXIBILITY IN
ORDER FOR US TO. MAXIMIZE THE
EFFICIENCY OF. THANK YOU
FINANCING TO LIKE TO PROVIDE ANY
. NOTICE COMMENT ON THE SIDE OF
A LA- WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROVIDE
ANY AND COMMON. NO ISSUES TO
RAISE WITH THE SCRIPT THANK YOU
THANK YOU ARE GOING TO IT BACK
TO MEMBERS OF THE- FOR DISCUSS
QUESTION SENATOR COPYRIGHT YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS I
DO AND I. FROM I RECEIVED- PHONE
CALLS FROM SOME OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAD RECEIVED.
ALL THESE NAMES- HOME KEY EITHER
HOME CARE ROOM KEY- IT KEEPS ONE
OF THE KEY YEAH- THAT GRANTS
AND- THE THEY WERE THAT THE
GRANTS WERE FEDERALLY PART OF
THE FEDERAL. MONEY THAT THE
STATE DISTRIBUTED FOR THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM- IN ORDER TO
HOUSE THE HOMELESS AND- IT WAS A
PURCHASE OF A- MOTEL TO
CONVERTED TO RESIDENTIAL USE AND
THE STATE HAD ALLOWED A SEQUEL
EXEMPTION FOR THESE KINDS OF
PROJECTS AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BALKED AT THE USE OF
FEDERAL FUNDSTO DO THIS
PROGRAM- WITHOUT GOING TO A
SECRET ANALYSIS WHICH WOULD
HAVE. TAKEN A LOT OF TIME AND
BASICALLY WOULD HAVE- WRIST A
RETURN OF THOSE FEDERAL FUNDS
BECAUSE- WE WERE COMPLYING WITH
THEIR THE RULES AND REGULATIONS
IS THAT ANTICIPATED IN IN THIS
BUDGET- ALLOCATION AND IS THAT
WHAT IS- REFERENCED WHEN YOU
YOU- IT MENTIONS THAT- THAT SOME
THAT THAT THERE'S A WAIVER OF
THE ADMINISTRATION AND
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT AS
WELL AS MAKING OTHER MINOR
ADMINISTRATIVE CHANGES. IS THAT
ONE OF THE MINOR ADMINISTRATIVE
CHANGES NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER
TWO IS HAVE YOU. WE BROUGHT THIS
ISSUE TO EACH CD BECAUSE- IT'S
VERY SERIOUS- AND I'M NOT SURE
THAT THE RESPONSE WE GOT BACK
WHICH WAS SATISFACTORY. YEAH
WE'RE FAMILIAR WITH THE ISSUE I
BELIEVE IT'S A PROJECT IN
SALINAS OBERNOLTE HI- THAT
ACTUALLY WASN'T AT HOME KEEP
USUALLY WORKS BECAUSE THEY WERE
COMBINING THE USE OF FEDERAL
VOUCHERS WHICH ARE MISTER BY
HOUSING AUTHORITY SO WE DON'T
HAVE CONTROL OVER THOSE PIECES-
WE WERE WE ARE ABLE TO
STREAMLINE THE STATE CONTROLLED
PIECES SO WHAT. WELL IT WAS NOT-
IT WOULD LEAD TO A DELAY THERE
IS NEEDED TO COMPLY WITH NEPA
ESSENTIALLY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S VERSION OF SEQUEL
WE CAN'T OF COURSE- CONTROL OR A
FACTUALLY CHANGE THERE WE ARE
TRYING TO WORK WITH OUR-
PARTNERS ON A NUMBER OF AREAS-
YOU CD AFFIRMATION IN THIS
PROGRAM WHICH IS A DIFFERENT
PROGRAM- DIFFERENT SORTS OF
FEDERAL FUNDS. THEY LOVE THE
HOKEY PROGRAM SO WE HAVE
OBVIOUSLY REYES TO THEM SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES WITH SOME OF
THOSE FEDERAL REGULATIONS WHAT
WE ASK FOR IN TERMS OF- ON THE
AT LEAST THE SIDE THAT WE
CONTROL OUR OWN STATE-
REGULATORY PROCESS. IS
GUIDELINES CREATE A LOT MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO SOMETIMES THE
FEDERAL RULES CHANGE IF THEN WE
WERE IN TURN YOU HAVE TO GO BACK
THROUGH A NOTHER REGULATORY
PROCESS ON OUR END WE WOULDN'T
BE WE WOULDN'T BE VERY NIMBLE IN
ORDER TO ADAPT TO THAT CHANGE
SO. FOR EXAMPLE IN THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS OF ENDEMIC WHEN OUR
DEPARTMENT RECEIVED QUITE A BIT
OF FUNDS- PULL THROUGH THE ESG
INCOMPATIBLE APOC GRANT PROGRAMS
HAD WE HAD TO GO THROUGH THOSE
PROCESSES WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO GET THOSE OUT TO
COMMUNITIES. F. MANNER BECAUSE
WE WOULD HAVE HAD TO UNDERGO
CHANGES- GOVERNANCE INSIGHTS
EXECUTIVE ORDERS TO ALLOW US TO
BYPASS THIS PROCESS EASIER BUT
NOW THAT WE'VE GOTTEN SOME
MOMENTUM WITH THE FACTS- IN THE
CREATION OF THIS PROGRAM THAT
ESSENTIALLY COMBINED SOME OF
THOSE USES WE DON'T WANT TO-
TAKE OUR FOOT OFF THE GAS. PEDAL
SO TO SPEAK SO THAT'S WHY THAT
WE SEE THAT REQUEST IT WILL FIX.
OUR NEED TO ESSENTIALLY COMPLY
WITH FEDERAL RULES REGULATIONS
WERE OF COURSE IN ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH TIED TO
INFORM THEM OF SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THEY CAN HAVE THAT
SOME OF THOSE- SOME OF SOME OF
THE EXERTIONS CARE AT FORTY ON I
NEED. BUT GO THROUGH- BUT COURSE
WE DON'T. WE HAVE TO GET TO THAT
PROCESS WITH THEM. WE DON'T HAVE
THE- AT STATE. TO CHANGE THE
RULES BUT THIS WELL AS- THAT
PROCESS. MINIMIZE THE AMOUNT
BERRIER. LIKE THE ONE YOU KNOW
TO. AT LEAST MAKE SURE THAT THE
STATE IS NOT PUTTING ANY VERY
AND PLACE. AN ORDER FOR THE
SPEAK FINISHED PRODUCTS- VERY
GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
I DO APPRECIATE IT- MY CONCERN
IS IF YOU NEED IF YOU. IF IN
ORDER FOR PROJECT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL YOU NEED VARIOUS
SOURCES OF REVENUE IN ORDER TO-
PAY DOWN THE COST OF THE
PROJECT. AND THERE'S ONE PART OF
THE- THE- THE SYSTEM THAT
REQUIRES DNIEPER SEQUIN ONE
WE'VE WAITED IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO GET PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS
AND INTO HOUSING AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. THAT THAT REALLY IS
GOING TO COME UP THE WORKS IN
THE MORE THAT WE CAN WORK WITH
OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS HAVE THEM
UNDERSTAND THAT- WE'RE ALL IN
THIS TOGETHER AND WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IT TOGETHER AND- WE WANT
TO USE THAT FUNDS AS EFFICIENTLY
AS POSSIBLE SO APPRECIATE YOUR-
YOUR- YOUR INFORMATION. WE SHARE
YOUR SENTIMENTS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I AM. JUST I JUST HAVE A
COUPLE OF WHAT I DID- NEW
FEDERAL PROGRAMS AND ACCESS TO
NEW A FEDERAL DOLLARS EXCITING.
I ALWAYS WANT TO- JUST FOR THE
RECORD SHARE THAT. I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
MINIMIZE THE COSTS. OF
REPACKAGING FEDERAL PROGRAM SO
THAT WE ARE MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE GETTING AS MUCH OF THOSE
DOLLARS- TO THE COMMUNITIES AS
POSSIBLE AND OFTEN TIMES. YOU
KNOW IF IT'S FEDERAL AND STATE
AND THEN REGIONAL EVERYONE'S
LIKE TAKING A PIECE AND THEN
THAT LESSENS. THE AMOUNT
AVAILABLE AT THE END TO ACTUALLY
DO THE WORK SO. THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY IN THE ANALYSIS BUT
I WANTED TO RAISE THAT- IN CASE
YOU HAVE A SENSE OF. THE COSTS
THAT WOULD BE ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT. OR JUST MAKING SURE THAT
THEY'RE MINIMIZED. A JOB THAT
YOU CAN GET CERTAINLY ELABORATE
I MEAN OUR ASSESSMENT IS IT WILL
TAKE US ABOUT FIFTEEN POSITIONS
THE CURRENT YEAR- AND- AS A FEW
AND ON GOING- MAYBE ADD A LITTLE
BIT OF. AT OF EVIDENCE HERE. FOR
THE MOST PART HCD WILL RECEIVE
FEDERAL FUNDS WERE HELPING TO
SMALLER AND MOST RURAL AND
SUBURBAN COMMUNITIES THE SMALLER
POPULATION COMMUNITIES THAT
DON'T RECEIVE DIRECT ALLOCATIONS
FOR CLASS SO. THEIR CAPACITY IS
LESS SO WE FIND THAT WE DO HAVE
TO PROVIDE QUITE A BIT OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WITH WE'RE
HAPPY TO DO- SOMETIMES AND EVEN
PROCURE ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS TO GOTTEN
THEIR COMMUNITIES. SO YEAH I
THINK THIS IS THIS IS FAIRLY
IT'S FAIRLY LEAN BUT IT ALSO
WASN'T ENOUGH FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT. AND SO THAT'S THAT'S
OUR SYSTEM AND- IT'S A BIT SO
THAT WE CAN HELP THOSE THOSE CAN
USE THAT TYPICALLY DON'T HAVE AS
MUCH- AS MUCH LOCAL STAFFING TO
COMPLY WITH ALL THE MANY FEDERAL
REGULATIONS OF THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS. OKAY THANKS YEAH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
MARKETING ARE OFTEN DIFFERENT
JUST WHINING I DEFINITELY AGREE-
TECHNICAL SUPPORT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR HELPING FOLKS
NAVIGATE. THROUGH THE DATE WITH
THE VARIOUS PROGRAMS THIS IS SO
I THINK I KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THIS BUT I JUST WANT TO ASK- AND
I KNOW THAT OFTENTIMES HOUSING
AUTHORITIES ARE ARE ARE SORT OF
TAX BASED BUT- IS IT POSSIBLE.
THAT SOME OF THESE FUNDS COULD
BE CONNECTED TO REGIONAL HOUSING
AUTHORITIES THAT ARE ALSO
INTERESTED IN THESE FOUR ARE
DOING SOME OF THESE- FIVE
ELIGIBLE ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
LISTED. YOU KNOW PRODUCING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SUPPORTING
WITH TENANT BASED ASSISTANCE
OFFERING SUPPORTIVE- AND HOUSING
HOMELESS PREVENTION SERVICES-
XCERRA. YEAH ALL THE DIVERSE OUT
OF THE JUST THE YOU IF YOU DID.
IF YOU WANT TO WEAR WE ARE AND
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY SPECIALLY
WHEN TAKE THE EXAMPLE HOME HE
WHICH IS CERTAINLY AN ELIGIBLE
USE HERE OR IN MANY NEW
PRODUCTION. KIND OF- FOR
PROGRAMS OFTEN HOUSING
AUTHORITIES ARE EITHER CO
APPLICANTS TO THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
PROVIDERS OF RESOURCES MOST
PROGRAMS ABOUT YOURS OR OTHER
MEANS. AND STILL DEPENDS UPON
THE STATE ON THE FERRY THE STATE
BUT THERE ARE SOME HOUSING
AUTHORITIES THERE QUITE INVOLVED
IN THE DEVELOPMENT PROCESS- AND
ARE OFTEN RECIPIENTS OF THESE
FUNDS AND PARTNERS WITH THEIR
OWN FUNDING SO YES. THAT IS TRUE
EVEN IF THEY ARE DIRECT
RECIPIENTS THERE OFTEN ENTITIES. THAT ARE HELPING THE POLICE. I
WOULD JUST NAY THAT ARE ALSO
FINDING OUR TRUE. HOUSE AT THE
SO IT IS BOTH THE CITIES THE
COUNTIES AND THE TRIBAL HOUSING
AUTHORITIES THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ENGAGE WITH UP
AND DOWN THE STATE TO REALLY
MAKE SURE. THAT WE BRING EVERY
RESOURCE. TO TRY AND HELP SO
MUCH FOR. OKAY GREAT- SO THIS IS
A HOLD OPEN ITEM. AND WITH THAT
I THINK THIS CONCLUDES THE
DISCUSSION ITEMS FOR PARK A AS
WELL AS THE DISCUSSION ITEMS FOR
PART B. I'M- OKAY I'LL WAIT TO
DO QUORUM. WILL GO INTO- NO
YOU'RE STAYING OKAY DOES IT MAKE
SENSE FOR US TO DO QUORUM NOW
YES WHY DON'T WE- MISTER
CONSULTANT COULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SO WE COULD ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. THAT'S OKAY. CABALLERO
HERE CABALLERO HERE NIELSEN ROTH
YOUR- THAT'S THREE- WE- SO WE
HAVE A QUORUM SO NOW WE'RE GOING
TO ACTUALLY MOVE ON ANYONE
WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT REGARDING ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA- BOTH PART A AND PART B.
AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE FOUR
ZERO. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE
CHAIRS MAY INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS
ON TESTIMONY TODAY I'M GOING TO
ASK THAT EACH MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC PROVIDING COMMENTS KEEP
THEIR REMARKS WITHIN ONE MINUTE
NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH WITNESSES
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. FOR
GOOD MORNING MARC STIVERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
AND ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
AN INFORMAL COALITION OF STATE
AND REGIONAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS DOES THE
CALIFORNIA. FOR WILL HOUSING
PARTNERS WE'RE HERE TO GIVE YOU
SOME LOVE SOME TANKS AND SOME
SUPPORT FOR THE SENATE'S
PROPOSED AUGMENTATIONS TO BOTH
THE MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
PROGRAM. THEY CALIFORNIA HOUSING
ACCELERATOR AND HOME KEY- THE
CALIFORNIA ACCELERATOR IS
ACTUALLY REALLY CRITICAL PIECE
WITH THE STATE AS MAXIMIZE IT
USED TO FEDERAL TAX EXEMPT BONDS
AND 4% LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDITS. WE HAVE LOTS OF
DEVELOPMENTS THAT OUR STATE HAS
ALREADY PUT MONEY INTO THAT ARE
NEEDING THESE CREDITS ARE SORT
OF STACKED UP IN A QUEUE IN A
BACKLOG AS IT WERE. AND THAT
HOUSING SOBRE HAS FREED UP
DOZENS AND DOZENS OF THOSE
DEVELOPMENTS TO MOVE INTO
CONSTRUCTION AND SO- ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THAT PROGRAM WILL ALLOW
THE NEXT GENERATION OF EACH YOU
FUND PROGRAMS TO MOVE ON. THE
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING PROGRAM IS
OUR PURPOSE EACH SHE'S PRIMARY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING RENTAL
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM IT
WAS FUNDED BY THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN PROP ONE- BOND. WE ARE
MAKING THE LAST OF THOSE AWARDS
NOW SO THE SENATE'S ADDITIONAL
APPROPRIATION WILL ALLOW THE
FUND THAT NEXT GENERATION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
AS WELL. AND HOME Q. ALL VERY
FAMILIAR WITH IT'S BEEN A
SUCCESS AND WE LIKE TO SEE THAT
PROGRAM EXPANDED AND CONTINUED
AS WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR SENATE SUPPORT YOU'VE BEEN
GREAT. THANK YOU THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS TRYING
TO GUEST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR RURAL
HOUSING AND THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
ALIGN MY SON MARI. ARE ARE. MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF MR
STIVERS AND PARTICULARLY PLEASED
TO SEE THE INVESTMENTS AND CAL
HOME AND THE JOE CERNER. FOR
HOUSING GRANT PROGRAMS BUT I
WANT TO- GOING BACK ISSUE EIGHT
FOCUS ON A DIFFERENT ISSUE WHICH
IS. A FUNDING FOR- PRESERVATION
MOBILE HOME PARK FOR PROPOSING
THE GOVERNOR IS TO PUT A
HUNDRED. MILLION WHICH WE
SUPPORT. INTO THE EXISTING
IMPROPER PROGRAM. THAT'S GREAT
WHAT WERE A BIT CONCERNED WITH.
A COMPANY IN TBL. WHICH WOULD
RENAME THE PROGRAM THE MORE
PROGRAM AND HAS A NUMBER OF
CHANGES. TRADITIONALLY THIS
FUNDING HAS BEEN THERE TO
PRESERVE MOBILE HOME PARKS
EITHER THROUGH RESIDENT
OWNERSHIP OR THROUGH. A
CONVERSION OR OR TRANSFER TO A
NONPROFIT MISSION DRIVEN
DEVELOPER WHO WILL KEEP THE
AFFORDABLE THIS PROGRAM FOR THE
FIRST TIME. IN THE TV I WOULD
PROPOSE TO ALLOW THAT FUNDING TO
GO TO A PRIVATE. FOR PROFIT
OWNER. TO FIX UP THEIR PARKS AND
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT WHILE THAT
MAY SOMETIMES BE USEFUL. THEY'RE
NOT A SUFFICIENT PARAMETERS IN
THERE TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
GETTING THE AFFORDABILITY OF
PROTECTIONS FROM DISPLACEMENT.
WE'RE ALSO LOSING SOME OF THE-
FAVORABLE LOAN TERMS- THAT ARE
SPELLED OUT IN THE STATUTE IN
FAVOR OF. ADOPTING AND
GUIDELINES WHO HAD CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND BRIEFLY
WITH YOUR STAFF ABOUT THOSE
CONCERNS AND OTHERS. WE HOPE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PROGRAM CONTINUES.
ITS PRIMARY FUNCTION BECAUSE IT
IS THE CURRENT. BALANCE THIS
COMES FROM. FEES PAID BY
HOMEOWNERS. THAT THE FUND IS
GOING PRIMARILY TO PRESERVING
PARKS AND THE LONG TERM
STABILITY FOR HOMEOWNERS SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THAT
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND IT'S GOOD MORNING AND
GOOD AFTERNOON WE STILL HAVE A
LITTLE TIME. STILL MORNING NO
MORNING HI MADAM CHAIR HOLLY FOR
MANY DAYS IS FROM MY HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS TODAY. AND ALSO
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE PROPOSALS
IN ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT. HERE ON
BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA'S FOR IN THE BLACK
LEADERSHIP. COUNCIL ONE ADDRESS
SPECIAL ATTENTION AND TO THE
REPOSE ON CAL. CAL HOMER THE
ONLY PROGRAM THE STATE BUDGET.
THAT IS ACTUALLY PRODUCING NEW
UNITS FOR LOW INCOME A VERY LOW
INCOME FAMILIES TO BUY HOMES THE
ONLY. PROPOSAL THAT IS FOCUSED
ON SUPPLY. THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION AS IN THE SENATE
PROPOSAL BUT WE STILL REQUESTING
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION. I'M IT IS
NOT ONLY AN OVERSUBSCRIBED
PROGRAM BUT IS ACTUALLY CAPPED
PER UNIT. AT ONLY A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PER UNIT AND FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION PER PROJECT. SO
INCREASING THIS- POOL OF FUNDS
FOR CALHOUN. WE ARE REALLY
HOPING THAT IT'S ALSO
COMPLIMENTED WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL TO TRY TO
GIVE SOME FLEXIBILITY ON THOSE
CAPS. THE BRIEF REALLY HELP THE
SENATE CONSIDERS. INCREASING NOT
TOTAL BUDGET- FROM THREE FIFTY
TO FOUR HUNDRED BILLION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. I'M SURE SENATOR
ROTH RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
THE AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION
IS HEALTHY HOUSING FOUNDATION.
WHICH OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS
HAS DEVELOPED. MORE THAN
THIRTEEN HUNDRED UNITS I'M IN
THIRTEEN PRODUCTS PROJECTS IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES FOR
EXTREMELY AND VERY LOW INCOME
PEOPLE VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE
PROGRESS THEY'RE MAKING- WE DO
WANT TO SEND A LOT OF LOVE TO
THIS COMMITTEE AND TO THE
BUDGET. COMMITTEES IN GENERAL
FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE
OVER THE LAST COUPLE YEARS IN
APPROPRIATING FUNDS FOR THESE
PURPOSES. AND THERE IS ONE AREA
THAT WE THINK DESERVES SOME
ADDITIONAL ATTENTION THAT IS AN
ADAPTIVE RE USE- THAT IS WHAT HF
HAS BEEN DOING OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS AS ADAPTIVE REUSE OF
EXISTING HOTELS AND MOTELS. AND
NOTWITHSTANDING THE SUCCESS OF
PROJECT HOME KEY- WE THINK THAT-
THE- LANDSCAPE NEEDS TO INCLUDE
MORE PROMINENT AND PERMANENT. A
FOR ADAPTIVE RE USE- OPTIONS-
FOR- FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE
ENCOURAGE THAT TO BECOME PART OF
THE- MORE MORE IN THE BDGET
THAN IT CURRENTLY IS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS- WE HAVE A PROS
UP PROPOSED ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE
THROUGH SENT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO DOUBLING THAT TO TWO
HUNDRED MILLION OVER THE NEXT
TWO YEARS- ADAPTIVE REUSE IS
MUCH. CHEAPER GENERALLY AND MUCH
SWIFTER IN TERMS OF ACHIEVING
THE PROJECT COMPLETION I'M WE
THINK IT NEEDS TO BE A MORE
PROMINENT P. SEVEN. THREE THINGS
WE'D LIKE YOU TO THINK ABOUT IN
ADDITION TO THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE WHAT ONE
IS I'M TAKING A LOOK GOOD LOOK
AT PROJECT HOME KEY AND HOW MUCH
IT'S COSTING- THERE WAS A- PRESS
RELEASE YESTERDAY WITH
ADDITIONAL PROJECTS THAT WERE
APPROVED. ON SOME OF THEM ARE
APPROACHING FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER UNIT- IN AN
ADAPTIVE RE USE- SITUATION THAT
SEEMS PRETTY HIGH TO US
CONSIDERING THE EXPERIENCE WITH
THAT- AND THEN LAST WE WOULD ASK
THAT THE- BUDGET TRAILER BILL
RELATIVE TO THIS ISUE- ALSO
ALLOW FOR ADAPTIVE REUSE. OF
EXISTING- HOTELS MOTELS AND
OTHER RESIDENTIAL SITUATIONS
CURRENTLY THE- OF THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE- IS ONLY
ON NON RESIDENTIAL AND
COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. SEE YOU
SAID THREE ITEMS BUT YOU ONLY
MENTION TO IS THE THIRD THE FOR
THE FIRST ONE WAS THE TWO. FROM
THE ONE. OKAY GREAT. ANYONE ELSE
IN HERE I SEE NO ONE OKAY SO NOW
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
TELEPHONE LINES. MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD OR MRS
MODERATOR- OR MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT WE CAN BEGIN. THANK
MANAGED CARE AND JUST AS A
REMINDER FOR THOSE ON THE PHONE
IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE A PAYMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IN AN
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU YOUR LIFE
NUMBER. THANK THE MOTORISTS
WOULD ALIGN. WE KNOW HOW MANY
HOURS YOU ARE IN THE QUEUE. YET
DESPITE WE HAVE- TWELFTH IN Q.
OKAY HIT IT. GREAT BAND PERSON
LINE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING TERRY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SAMANTHA THING
WITH NEXT IN CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ISSUE THIRTY
EIGHT IN PART A OF YOUR AGENDA
THE TEN MILLION FORGET K. TO
CONDUCT THE STUDENT BAR OUR
REGION EDUCATION CAMPAIGN WOULD
ALSO REQUEST AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY MILLION FOR THIS PURPOSE
FOR A TOTAL OF THIRTY MILLION.
PEOPLE AND SYSTEMS TO CONVOLUTED
INFLUX FOR THE AVERAGE FARMER TO
NAVIGATE WITHOUT ASSISTANCE AN
EXISTING RESOURCES ARE
INSUFFICIENT TO ASSIST BORROWERS
WHO NEED HELP A KEY PART OF THE
FBI PLAN WILL BE TO LEVERAGE
TRUSTED MESSENGERS TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION GRANT. EACH
STUDENTS. BORROWERS TO INTO
REGIONS PROPOSED MILLION. BUDGET
BECAUSE THE THIRD MILLION OR- I
THREE YEARS ON THAT ITEM. ON Q.
AND PART A OF YOUR AGENDA TODAY-
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
THE ADMINISTRATION TO MODERNIZE
STATE OPERATIONS. WITHOUT A
RACIAL EQUITY LINE SO WE ARE
CONCERNED AGENCIES PROGRAMS AND
POLICIES WILL CONTINUE TO
PERPETUATE SYSTEMIC RACISM. WE
HOPE THE COMMITTEE WILL CONSIDER
FUNDING SB SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR
PAN TO INSTITUTIONALIZE
POPULATE. TO MEANINGFULLY
ADDRESS SYSTEMIC AND PUT IT IN
EQUITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT IT EXTRA LINE THREE. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HONORABLE JERRY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS AMY HINES
SHAIKH WITH WILDCAT CONSULTING
AND I'M REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND TRUST
NETWORK AND THEY'RE TWENTY SIX
THE L. P. AFFILIATES ACROSS THE
STATE HELLO HOUSING NOW
COALITION WITH OVER NINETY
MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS STATEWIDE.
BOTH THE COMMUNITY LAND TRUST
THAT WORK AND HELPING NOW ARE
UNITED IN THEIR BUDGET REQUEST
FOR THE COMMUNITY ANTI
DISPLACEMENT AND PRESERVATION
PROGRAM OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE
CAP CHAMPION BY MR BLOOM IN THE
ASSEMBLY THE PROPOSAL WOULD FUND
THE ACQUISITION OF CURRENTLY I'M
SUBSIDIZED AFFORDABLE RENTAL
HOUSING ENABLING MISSION DRIVEN
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING SKILLED
HE'S TO PURCHASE THESE BUILDINGS
AND PRESERVATION OF AFFORDABLE.
A FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN THE PROGRAM COULD%
CREATE APPROXIMATELY FOUR
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED SPEED
RESTRICTED UNIT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE FUTURE
VERSIONS OF THE SENATE BUDGET AS
WELL AND- TO ADDRESS- SENATOR
HOW GYROS LAMENTING THAT WE
DON'T GET THE STATE HE LOVE WE
REALLY DO LOVE THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM FOR ALL PROGRAM EVERYTHING
YOUR AGENT THAT TODAY- WE'RE
VERY HAPPY TO SEE IT IN THE
SENATE BUDGET BLUEPRINT AND JUST
WOULD LIKE. THAT COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST MODEL TO BE CONTEMPLATED
IN THAT- REGARDING THE
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION PROGRAM
WHICH WAS AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN FROM LAST YEAR HOUSING NOW
WITH THE STATIC COMPUTERS IN THE
SENATE BUDGET P. PRINT AND WE
REALLY DO NEED AT LEAST ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION IN
THAT AREA TO MAKE IT WORK AND
ASSIST CALIFORNIANS IN STAYING
IN THEIR HOME. AND FINALLY THE
FUNDING MECHANISM FOR EASY
EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN A FIVE YEAR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT TO CREATE THE REENTRY
HOUSING AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM I'M NOT A
CHAMPION BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRIAN IN THE ASSEMBLY AND WE DO
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
IN THE FUTURE AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION TO
THESE MATTERS. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. THE LINE NUMBER TWO TWO.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT MORE NINE TURN MY NAME
IS SARAH OF ITS AND CALL ON
BEHALF OF YOUNGER. INTO OF THE
BORROWED DEFENSE BROKE UNDER A
THIRTY. THE REQUESTED TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TIME FOR THE FBI
. THE REQUESTED THAT TEN MILLION
DOLLAR FUND BE TRICKLE TO THIRTY
NINE TO MAKE THE NEEDS OF THE
OVER FOUR MILLION TO TOMORROW IN
CALIFORNIA. THE STUDENT LOAN
SYSTEM IS TOO COMPLICATED INFLUX
OF THE AVERAGE FAR REACHING
WITHOUT A SYSTEM. REPUBLICAN OF
THE CURRENT PAYMENT BECAUSE AN
ONGOING SHIFT SERVICES RUSAL IN
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS ACCOUNT. IN TRANSPORTATION COMPANIES.
THE HAS INTRODUCED. LAYERS FROM
. CONFUSION EXISTING. ARE IN THE
TO THE FARM NEED HELP. NOW IS
THE TIME AND DOES IN SUPPORT
WITH THE- OF BUYER. THE ONE TO A
GENERATION OPPORTUNITY FOR SO
WORKERS ACCESS THE PUBLIC THE-
FOR. PUT PREVIOUSLY AN ELEGY
WITH THE- ABOUT THIRTY FOR. YES
IS THE- NATION IN TERMS OF
SUPPORT THE HOME BUYER REYES HE
COULD POSITION TO BE SO. READ
ALL THE REVIEWS BECAUSE THE
PROPOSAL HELLO DOLLAR PER. WHICH
TO THIRTY MILLION. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. IT
WILL BUILD LINE NUMBER THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORE
REMEMBER IT BECAUSE LOOK AT
PREVENTING FELT HOLD FOR YOUTH
NINE IF YOU'VE- ARE WANTED TO
pFUND AND HOME PACKAGE. I KNOW WE
PUT YOU IF WE STATUS ON. AN
INCREASE IN BACK NOT HOT
PROGRAMS AND ARGUED AGAINST YOUR
LEADERSHIP THE PART OF YOUNG ARE
YOUNG AND- AND INCREASING NOT
EVEN GREATER 104225% WE CAN GET
OF. THE GROWING KANA OF THE-
BECAUSE HAD UNDER AND BACK FOR
YOU FOR MANY YEARS. AND I
APPRECIATE HIS HELP ON FOR
PROJECT HOME HE AND WITH AND A
WIENER. I HAVE HAD AT THE THIRTY
FOUR SUPPORT WHICH REALLY.
CREATE MORE OPPORTUNITIES NON
SERVICE PROVIDERS WHO ARE DOING
THE DIRECT SERVICE WORK WITH OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE THE INBOX TO CARE
THAT WOULD NOT BE FOSTER CARE
AND TO BE ABLE TO ACT THE FUNDS
DIRECTLY TO BRING IN PROGRAMS
AND HOUSING OPTIONS FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO MEET THEIR NEEDS. AND
RESPOND TO THEM AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT. AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. WE'LL GO TO TWENTY
EIGHT LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS CARLY
SHALL BE CALLING ON OF THE MAYOR
SCHAAF TO THE OF THE CITY MAYOR
COLIN THE YEAR OF YOU KNOW THE
CITY NUMBER ONE CRARY CONTINUE
TO BE A CAL HOME CRIME. WE THINK
MINUTES THE- PRINT CONTINUED
SUPPORT OF FUNDING FOR THE WHOLE
OF THE HOUSING. AND PREVENTION
HOW PROGRAM THE POWER YEAR. VERY
GRATEFUL AND APPRECIATIVE THE
SENATE MULTI YEAR CLOSE THAT
SEEKS TO AND FUNDING TO HOW
ADDRESS THE IN HOUSE. WE
RECEIVED. REQUEST IS ALLOCATED
TO THE HOUSE GRAHAM SAID TO
PROVIDE MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY FOR
CITY. ACROSS FOR A BILL I FOR
THE YEARS LOOK FOR TO OUR GOING
. SENATE ASSEMBLY AND THE
MINISTRATION. THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON A DRAFTING OR
OF PRESSING. AND FOR CAN THE-
WITH OUR LARGE CITIES IT LOOKS.
TO WITH YOU DROPPING BUDGET PROP
THAT. ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
LEADERSHIP THINKING. THANK YOU
NEXT CALL. IT NEXT LITTLE NUMBER
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING JERRY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
RYAN JOY AND I AM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA YIMBY I
WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT OUR
SUPPORT FOR A THREE ITEMS IN
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT- FIRST WE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED ACT
CALIFORNIA DREAM FOR ALL
PROGRAMS- AND ALSO THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE IN
FUNDING FOR AID YOU FINANCING
ASSISTANCE- AND LASTLY WE ALSO-
SUPPORT THE INCREASE IN FUNDING.
FOR THE SENATE BUDGET PROPOSAL
FOR CALIFORNIA IT WOULD ASK YOU
INCREASE IT FROM THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS TO FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS I'D
OUTLINED I- BY QUALITY AFTER
MEDIAN DAYS USE- WHAT A PART AT
. FOR CHIEF BE APPETITE FOR
HUMANITY OP ALL THE WAY THEY'VE
DONE FOR PUSHING FOR THE PROGRAM
IN FORWARD THANK YOU MUCH THANK
YOU NEXT. CALLER IN ORDER TO
LINE NUMBER TWENTY NINE PLEASE
AHEAD. THE MORNING CARE MEMBERS
MARINO LANGUAGE CALIFORNIA HAS
CONSORTIUM I'LL LARGE AT MY COME
THAT MR CYBER. EARLIER ANTICS
OUR SHE- FOR PROPOSED IN IN THE
AN H. P. PROGRAM FOR HOUSING
SALARIES PROGRAM HELP KEEP.
THANK THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. IT WILL NOT ALLOW THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR- MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS YOU LOOK AT OPENING ON
CALL ON BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE
FOR HELPING SOLUTION. I AM
CALLING TO ASK THE SECOND SECOND
MAYBE CONSIDER SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASING THE INVESTMENT TO BE
INSULIN CONSTRUCTION GRANT
PROGRAM AND WOULD LIKE FOR THE
PROGRAM TO BE EXPANDED TO
INCLUDE NEW ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA
TO INCENTIVIZE BUILDING IN AREAS
THAT ALSO FOR THE STATE WE HOUSE. GAS EMISSION TARGETS. AS WE
ALL KNOW IMPRESSED. IS THE ONLY
THING WE CAN ACTUALLY INSURE THE
EACH DENTAL. IS SECURE WHETHER
IT BE PROMOTED HELPING
AFFORDABLE. EMERGENCY SHELTERS
WE REALLY NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THE PROGRAM IS REVITALIZED. TO
ENSURE THAT IT IS SOMETHING
ABOUT THE STATE. TO WORK FULL
WHEN IT COMES TO HELPING AND
CLIMATE CHANGE WITH FORWARD TO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSIONS WITH YOUR
COMEDIAN APPRECIATE THE TIME.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. WE WILL
Y. NUMBER THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JENNIFER STACK
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS
HOMEOWNERSHIP PROVIDES WORKING
FAMILIES WITH THE UNPARALLELED
ABILITY TO ACCRUE GENERATIONAL
WEALTH AND EXPERIENCE HOUSING
SECURITY. CALIFORNIA DELEGATION
OF REALTORS STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THE SENATE'S PROPOSED INVESTMENT
POLICIES TO CREATE MORE HOME
OWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STATES WORKING FAMILIES.
SPECIFICALLY WITH SUPPORT
FUNDING THAT CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA DREAM FOR ALL OF
PROGRAM WE ALSO SUPPORT CHILDREN
NINE DOLLARS TO CALIPHATE CHASE
DOWN PAYMENT SSISTANCE PROGRAM
FIFTY MILLION FOR CALIPHATE
EIGHTY YOU CONSTRUCTION FINANCE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS AND THE
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR CALIFORNIANS. THAT
WOULD BE A MAJOR MILESTONE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S WORKING FAMILIES AS
WE SEEK TO HELP CLOSE THE WEALTH
GAP IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED IN ITS
WORK ON THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR CAN. YOU
LET US KNOW HOW MANY MORE FOLKS
ARE IN THE QUEUE. WE HAVE SIX IN
THE- OKAY. NEXTSTEP WELL THE
LINE NUMBER TWO THREE PLEASE
AHEAD. SERIOUSLY ORLANDO KIANA
SECURE DATA BEHALF OF THE HOUSE
ACTION COALITION WE LIKE TO
THANK THE SENATE FOR THEIR
PROPOSAL ON THE FUNDING FOR THE
CALHOUN PROGRAM IN MOLECULAR
LINER COMMENTS WITH THE COMMENTS
MADE EARLIER REGARDING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THAT
PROGRAM I THINK IT'S A REALLY-
IMPORTANT INVESTMENT ALSO
SUPPORTED OF THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE DOWN
PAYMENT ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THANK
YOU AGAIN TO THE SEVEN FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
AND A LITTLE NUMBER. SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SINCE BUT TO MILLION
REPRESENTING US INTO CRISIS
CENTER AND OUR TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND- SUPPORTERS IN HERE TO
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
BUDGET ITEM. EIGHT AND HARD AB
WHICH ONES- YEAH ACTUALLY I.
LOAN BORROWER. BOB BUT MILLION
IT NOT ENOUGH TO ADDRESS SKILL
THE PO SO WE DO URGING TO MIN TO
FOR REAL MEANINGFUL. IT'S QUITE
SIMPLE BOB WHAT FUNDS AVAILABLE
- THE TO AFTER TO MORE CAL FOR
NO STUDENTS BORROWERS WE CAN BE
YOU COMMUNITY GROUPS AFTER
CAMPAIGN. THAT MUCH MORE OF THE
WAY THAT THINGS TODAY IF IS FOR
TOO CALM. AND YES IN PLACE
REALLY FAIL MANY OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE PARTICULARLY BLACK.
AND BROWN BORROWERS. HE WILL
INVESTORS TIME MONEY TREAT
BORROWER YEAH THIS. WHAT THAT
ARE ACTUALLY THE RIGHT IT'S THE
KIND OF INVEST IN SUPPORT
BORROWERS THIS YEAR ALONE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE FOR REAR THE
PAYMENT WHEN AND THEN BELIEVE
AND POP MANY TO PASTORS CHANGE
OR SUBJECT TO PUT THAT HAVE
WEAKENED THE RULE FOR NOW IS THE
TIME TO BIG FOOD MATHIS ON PRESS
OPPORTUNITY. TO REALLY HELP OUR
WERE- AND I CAN SAY FROM OWN
EXPERIENCE WHICH OUT TO BUY AND
HELPING- OVER THE YEARS THAT
EACH DOLLAR DEFICIT YOU SHOULD
ALWAYS MEANS SHOULD SAVINGS THEM
AND THEIR FAMILY CALIFORNIA HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A LEADER CHAMPION
STUDENT LOAN BORROWERS AND
PROVIDING THIS TYPE OF REALLY
MEANINGFUL SUPPORT THE NEXT STEP
IN THIS LEGACY NOW IS THE TIME
TO INVEST. UP WE DO SUPPORT
AGAIN- INVESTING IN DFU ARE
REJECTED EFFORTS BUT WE URGE YOU
THINK TO THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR ALL TO FUND THIS TYPE OF
WORK THANK YOU THANK YOU I'M
GOING TO ASK FOR THE REMAINING
CALLERS IN THE QUEUE IF YOU CAN
SELF REGULATE THE AS I MENTIONED
AT THE BEGINNING WE WANT TO KEEP
FOLKS SAYS THAT TESTIMONY TWO
ONE MINUTE SO WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYONE HAS A CHANCE TO BE
HEARD. MISTER MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. AND THEY'LL BE NUMBER
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY IS AND LAMELLA
AND I AM SO ABOUT OF JOE BURTON
FOR YOU IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
HOMELESS HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND
PREVENTION PROGRAM WHICH
INCLUDED YOU CAN SET ASIDE TO
ADDRESS A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE
ABUSE HOMELESSNESS IN THE STATE.
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH
ADDITION THREE PUBLICATIONS ON
TAP AND FOUND THAT THE PROGRAM
IS AN EFFECTIVE STRATEGY TO
ADDRESS YOUTH HOMELESSNESS WHICH
IT HAS EXPANDED THE CONTINUE ON
HOUSING OPTIONS FOR HOMELESS
YOUTH. AND INTEGRATED LOOK AT TO
THE LOCAL HOMELESS RESPONSE
NETWORK SHOULD COUNTIES REPORT
THAT THE HAPPY SATISFIED IS A
SINGULAR STRATEGY TO PREVENT
ADULT ALMOST US MOST IMPORTANTLY
HAPPENS ASSISTED OVER ELEVEN
THOUSAND YOUNG PEOPLE TAKING
THEM OFF THESTREETS OUT OF
HARM'S WAY AND ON A PATH TO
ECONOMIC SECURITY THE
RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST ADDITIONAL
ATTACHMENT HALF. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. IT WILL GO TO THE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS CORNELIUS
BURKE OR THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION I WILL BE
EXTREMELY BRIEF WE. SHARP
HOMEOWNERSHIP IS SO IMPORTANT TO
BOOST GENERATIONAL WEALTH
POTENTIALLY FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR-
WE SUPPORT THE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE WE SUPPORT EIGHTY
FINANCING- PROGRAM ONE THING
THAT WE WOULD RESPECT REQUEST IS
TO INCREASE THE CAO HOME FUNDING
TO AT LEAST FOUR HUNDRED NINE
DOLLARS. WE APPLAUD DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
INCREASE. FUNDING TO HELP WITH
SUPPLY SIDE- SUPPLY AND DOWN
PAYMENT IS A MATCH MADE IN
HEAVEN TO REALLY HELP
CALIFORNIANS FEEL THE DREAM OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR OF THE BILL TO COMMENT
TODAY. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
THE WIND NUMBER FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION I
JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT WHILE
HOMELESSNESS IS LOOKS VISIBLE ON
CALIFORNIA'S THE STREET IS ALSO
BECOME INCREASINGLY PREVALENT IN
OUR TRANSIT SYSTEM. IN FACT THE
STUDY RELEASED BY THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIANS TO THE
TRANSPORTATION STUDY FOUND THAT
APPROXIMATELY 85% OF TRANSIT
AGENCIES SURVEYED DESCRIBED
HOMELESSNESS AS A CHALLENGE TO
THEIR SYSTEM THE ONLY 50% OF
THAT DESCRIBED INCREASE IN
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ON THE SYSTEM YOU
TO THE PANDEMIC HI THIS IS A
CHALLENGE THAT IS MOST ACUTE IN
PUBLIC SPACES INCLUDING OUR
STOPS OR STATIONS. AND OUR
PLATFORM TO THE GREATEST IMPACT
BEING FELT IN HIGH COST AREAS OF
THE STATE INCLUDING LOS ANGELES
AND THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
AGENCIES ARE NOT THEMSELVES
DIRECTLY ELIGIBLE FOR VARIOUS
FUNDING PROGRAMS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE THE BOTTOM LINE TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS WE
THEREFORE REQUESTED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS CONSIDERING NEW
INVESTMENTS. TO FURTHER ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS THAT ALSO CONSIDER
EXPANDING PROGRAM PARAMETER TO
INCLUDE TRANSIT AGENCIES
ABSTRACT FUNDING RECIPIENTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
. AND WE WILL TALK TO ONE UP FOR
ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
MONEY THAT ONE. THANK YOU FOR
THE TO OFFER PUBLIC. ON A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER WORK WITH ALL THE
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES ACROSS
OUR STATE. FOUR AND THE PRIVATE
PROTECTION NBC FOR FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. HOWEVER
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
ABOUT HOW THE AGENCY HAS IGNORED
THE VOICES AND CONCERNS OF SMALL
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES. LAST
WEEK THE AGENCY HELD THREE
MEETINGS TO GET FEEDBACK FROM
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE AND IF YOU
COMPARE CORPORATE PRIVACY
REGULATIONS. BUT HOW THE SMALL
BUSINESS PEOPLE TO PROVIDE
FEEDBACK ON DRAFT REGULATIONS
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN RELEASED. ALL
BUSINESS OWNERS INVESTING THEIR
TIME AND RESOURCES ON KEEPING
THEIR DOORS OPEN AND CONDUCTING
MORE BUSINESS ONLINE. NOT
MONITORING AGENCY MEETING. THAT
HAVE JOBS- CUSTOMER SERVICE
EMPLOYEES TO LOOK AFTER
INFIRMITIES TO BILLS. MY DUTY AS
A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER TO SHED
LIGHT ON THE FACT THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN NO MEANINGFUL OUTREACH
TO BUY BUSINESSES. HELLO HAS
THERE BEEN ANY ECONOMIC IMPACT
ON THE RATE. WILL HAVE ON OUR
BUSINESS THIS. BUT WE HAVE NO
IDEA MANY BY OWNED. BEFORE THE
CLOSE OF THE FINE STABILITY OF
THE OF REGULATIONS. WOULD NOT
MIND IF THE- THAT REPRESENT THE
LIVE OF TENS OF TELEPHONE FAMILY
AGENCY SHOULD SIGNIFICANT
SERIOUSLY. UNFORTUNATELY THAT
HAVE INVADED OF QUESTIONS AND
AVOIDED DEALING WITH. BLACK
BUSINESSES. THANK YOU. THANK.
YOU NEXT CALLER. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER FORTY PLEASE BOY.
FIND FORTY THREE ALLIES OPEN.
ABRAM DEAR PARK AT THE FOR I
THINK. NONPROFIT HOUSING FIFTIES
ACCORDING YOUR SENATE BOB OUT IN
THE BUDGET AND I SPECIFICALLY
SUPPORTING IN IN THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR CAO HOME OFFICE
THEREFORE FUNDING REQUEST FOR
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THEY DO A LOT OF GREAT WORK TO
HELP SUPPORT HOMEOWNERSHIP FOR
LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND THINK
THAT THIS WOULD BE IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT ALLOCATION TO ADVANCE
IN THE OWNERSHIP GOALS AND
GENERAL INCOME HOUSING GOALS OF
THE OVERALL SENATE AND THE
STATE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
TIME AND APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTION. GREAT THANK YOU AB MR
MODERATOR. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
THE- AND KILL OKAY. HAVING HEARD
FROM ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE- I'M
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SENATORS. ROTH AND
COPIER- DO YOU HAVE ANY FINAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. A THREE
FROM MADAM CHAIR THE ONLY- AS
FULL A COMMENT THAT I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT WE'VE PULLED IS
THE- IS THE- I GUESS IT'S ISSUE
THIRTY SIX CALIFORNIA PRIVACY
PROTECTION AGENCY. THE CONSUMER
PRIVACY IMPLEMENTATION AND
ENFORCEMENT ISSUE- I MY
UNDERSTANDING US WE'LL TAKE THAT
UP AT A DIFFERENT TIME. GREAT
THAT'S ALL I HAVE THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU SO NOW WE ARE
GOING TO GO TO THE VOTES WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH PART EIGHTY
FROM THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR- I
WANT TO REITERATE THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE DOING A VOTE ONLY ON
PART EIGHT. ITEMS ONE ISSUES ONE
TO THIRTY FIVE. ISSUE THIRTY SIX
HAS BEEN PULLED IS OUR MOTION.
SO MOVED FROM SENATOR ROBB- MR
HACKER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COME WATER. I CABALLERO AYE
NIELSEN. ROTH ALL RIGHT. THAT
MEASURE ALL THREE ZERO MINUTES
PUT ON CALL FOR A SECOND WILL
NOW MOVE TO PART BE UNFIT FOR%
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR- PART B.
VOTE ONLY AS ISSUES ONE THROUGH
SEVEN DO WE HAVE A MOTION. SO
MOVE FROM SENATOR CABALLERO MR
HACKER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CALL
LOGGER I HAVE A HERO HI NIELSEN.
ROTH ALL RIGHT THAT MOTION GETS
OUT WITH A THREE ZERO LOSS OF
PLACE ON CALL AND WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE DISCUSSION ITEMS FOR
PART B. THESE ARE DISCUSSION
ITEMS TEN. ISSUE TEN IN ISSUE
ELEVEN IS THERE A MOTION. SO
MOVE FROM SENATOR ROTH MR HACKER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL KAMLAGER HI
CABALLERO. HI NIELSEN. ROTH I'VE
THAT MEASURE AS A THREE ZERO
PLACE IT ON HOLD- WAIT FOR
SENATOR NIELSEN TO MAYBE CALL-
SO I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING I EITHER REMOTELY
OR IN PERSON IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR YOU CAN VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO ALL
OF US THAT WE WANT TO INCLUDE
YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
AND YOUR COOPERATION WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR TODAY'S
HEARING- THE SENATE BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER FOUR IS ADJOURNED.